this is oh here we go okay we're live
RFK Jr is preparing an independent run
so say the reports and based on the
polling data it looks like this will be
a major spike for Democrats and now Ross
Perot is trending on Twitter but uh I
like RFK Jr I think he knows what he's
doing and uh should be interesting
obviously there was very very big news
there's not much to add to it but rest
in peace Senator Feinstein she passed
away
that's the news you know a sad story but
uh this is what happens people get old
they they pass on so I can give respect
to the public service but uh outside of
that I must be honest I am no fan of the
professional lives of 99 of these people
who are in Congress anyway so human
respect rest in peace Diane Feinstein
and uh it's I believe Gavin Newsom is
going to be uh choosing a a replacement
which will be interesting because now
you've got uh Bob Menendez on the ropes
they want him to resign he's not gonna
with Feinstein out this weekend's
Democratic control of the Senate but I
think they'll be fine before we get
started on the news my friends head over
to Tim guest.com click timcast IRL X
Miami pick up your tickets the event is
next Friday in one week we will see all
of you live Friday October 6 Miami with
Patrick about David James O'Keefe Matt
Gates Lou gradkowski meaning will be
there gonna have a whole bunch of guests
there Phil's going to be there we got
Alex Stein who is going to be performing
a stand-up set just before the show we
have a pre-show with Public Square who's
sponsoring the event we have an after
show just for you guys and this special
event Friday night the Friday episode
next week will be exclusive to
timcast.com members only we are hoping
that events like this can help support
the the company the website the shows
that we do and be a great way to help
build the membership because go to
timcast.com click join us when you're a
member it's not just about
watching these shows or watching the
uncensored show it's that we've got a
lively community of people of members
who host morning shows where they all
talk to each other after shows where
they hang out and talk about the show
and they're working on projects together
so if you're looking to be involved if
there are thing if there are people you
want to meet and talk to find
like-minded individuals become a member
at timcast.com because you're going to
be watching various shows that we
produce you're going to be watching and
listening to the shows the members are
producing and you guys are going to be
sharing ideas so shout out to the
Discord members who are doing all of
this really awesome work building
culture and if you want to support our
endeavors with our coffee shop with our
anti-time square and all the things
we're working on become a member at
timcast.com and again shout out to
Public Square One of the most effective
Tools in winning the culture War
sponsoring our Miami event download the
app it's an app where you can find
businesses that have pledged to support
American values so you can support all
the goodbycots only buy from those
companies support them let people who
buy from people who believe in your
values also smash the like button
subscribe to this channel share the
share with your friends joining us
tonight to talk about this and so much
more is Rich Barris
it's good to be back Tim thanks for
having me uh who are you what do you do
pollster people's pundit uh you know I'm
thinking about this RFK thing yeah you
know I just start rolling on it well it
is really interesting that every so
often we have a guest perfectly aligned
with the big story and right now the big
stories that RFK is gonna run is
planning to run as an independent and
then we have
the people's funded here to talk about
polling but uh we'll get into in a
second we'll run through these uh
introductions so we've got Phil Labonte
hanging out hello everybody my name is
Phil Labonte lead singer of All That
Remains very failed musician
anti-communist and counter-revolutionary
thank you rock star cheers Ian Crossland
happy to be here I'm looking for much
fun yeah it is just gets better and
better with age uh well Serge take us
take us home because I want to hear
about it let's get started I am
search.com uh yeah here's this here's
the story from the post-millennial
breaking RFK Jr plans to announce
independent run for President Kennedy
plans to make the announcement on
October 9th in Philadelphia good place
to do it according to Media Kennedy
plans to make the announcement October
9th in Philly with a text message viewed
by the outlet stating that his campaign
is planning attack ads against the
Democrat National Committee to pave the
way for the announcement Bobby feels the
DNC is changing the rules to exclude his
candidacy so an independent run is the
only way to go
on Saturday New York Times published a
piece stating that Kennedy met with
libertarian party chair Angela McArdle
in July at a Memphis Congress I'm sorry
at a Memphis conference he emphasized
that he has committed to running as a
Democrat but so that he considered
himself very libertarian
McArdle said adding we're aligned on a
lot of issues including the threat of
the deep State here's what I think I
think they gave Kennedy the middle
finger which they should not have done
he's pulling decently I mean polls have
him in a wide range from Seven up to 25
percent I think you were saying before
the show that Seven's a little low 25 is
a little high but if he runs an
independent and he goes after the DNC
over this he is spiking the Democratic
party is going to help Trump this is a
couple of things one if you're Trump
though we had been asking if your guy
doesn't get the nomination what are you
gonna do and 33 of Republicans yeah of
all everyone of everyone everyone so if
for the Democrats people who chose RFK
30 something percent for months have
said well if it's Trump I'll vote for
Trump so if you're Trump you're looking
at it you're like I want some soon to be
disaffected RFK voters like Bernie
voters in 2016. right so there's that
part of it there is scant polling on
this we're going to pull this we're
gonna pull this and we're gonna pull
this soon to see you know uh Biden the
Democrat Trump the Republican uh and of
RFK the independent and we'll put West
in there too we'll see what it really
you know that that's going to happen
he'll be on the ballot Cornell um oh
yeah I mean Democrats are gonna get
spiked across the board if this goes if
yeah I mean if this goes bad for
Democrats which you know it may not I
mean I'll wait to see what the data says
but you know you know if it does you're
looking at the Ross Perot analogy is
accurate then folks you know it would be
really hilarious though there's a lot
you know Mike cernovich's got a series
of tweets that we're going to talk about
a second very dire ones but uh you know
this fear of losing in 2024 and I'm just
kind of like could you imagine if it's
like Donald Trump gets 43 of the vote
but Biden because of Cornell West and
RFK only gets like 39.
and he won he'll wind up with Tim he'd
win States Republicans don't win if that
happens all right okay uh no I mean
Trump he would take like remain you know
he's definitely gonna take Maine uh
there would be some states that are
really uncomfortable so so let's let's
think about like let's let's let's Okay
Maine yeah how how uh what percentage
does the Republican candidate get in
Maine on average for the president
depends if you're Donald Trump you get
pretty close you take the second
congressional district then you can get
within eight points usually which
doesn't sound like a lot but it doesn't
have big population so uh so uh what
what did we have so that means Trump's
at uh what is that with an eight point
set what does that put him at 46 to
Biden's 54. yeah I think it was yeah I
think it was I think have 44 last time
something like that and then Biden ended
up with like 42 or 43. well no 50 52
inmates oh wow so well I mean I was I I
didn't realize he lost that much of the
remaining votes yeah if though let's say
West is on there he takes four so now
RFK takes 10. and then you're looking
right into 38 Trump wins Maine with 45
this is it's a game changer man you
mentioned Ross Pro what happened in 92 I
don't know if people listening even know
the Ross Pro story but he came out of
out of nowhere a business sector and ran
for president 1992 against George
Herbert Walker Bush and Bill Clinton and
everyone expected George Herbert Walker
Bush to win his second term as president
he was the incumbent but the Ross Perot
split the vote and then Clinton took it
yeah Clinton never was elected with the
majority people don't really get lost
back on him right yeah oh way less 44
right
um they look back at him and he's got a
high hindsight approval rating so people
are like oh well he must have you know
they just think he he blazed right past
Bush and then Dole he didn't
um there is though something that's
nagging me in the back of my mind though
he's an anti-establishment guy and when
you have two anti-establishment guys
it just I I'm looking at it as a lane
you know we'll see I disagree I disagree
the the there are leftist
anti-establishments that's true but like
very few and what I think you have
2016 where was I I was like I would I I
said I said in 2016 I'm not voting for
Trump 2015 I'm not voting for Trump 2017
2018 2019 then 2020 Trump put out his
list of what his plan was and then I
said like if this is Trump's plan the
these agenda items I agree with too much
of this honestly say I would vote
against it and considering they're
trying to run Joe Biden and we know what
Biden's all about I cannot honestly say
I could support the Democratic Party
there were a lot of people who were
still Democrats who voted in 2020 for
for Biden who are now saying it was a
mistake but some of these people are
saying please let it be RFK or literally
anyone else they are begging Biden not
to be there if Biden is the nominee and
RFK runs an independent there are people
who are Democrats who are upset about
what happened with Joe Biden are upset
of the state of the country but still
won't vote for Trump
they'll either not vote vote West or
vote uh RFK Trump's floor is solid
that's right yes Trump's bottom end is
locked in you are like the Maga people I
think so I mean I don't think it works
out you know the mega people are are
just they're not going to change no
matter what you I mean he was right when
he said you know I could go out in Fifth
Avenue and shoot someone and they would
still vote for him that is still the
case the people that love Donald Trump
love him to death I don't think that uh
I don't think that that there's a whole
lot of chance for Joe Biden if it's
split up between you know between
Kennedy and uh I forget what his name is
we were just talking about him West West
you know West I mean though they will
split the Democrat and no I don't like
Trump vote up and I think enough where
Trump would get in now this is this is
just talking a year and a half or a year
and change early so obviously all this
can change and this is just my first
impression but I I'm confident that
Donald Trump's floor isn't changing yeah
so yeah can let me just point out what
because nobody talks about this what
they did to this guy
changing the schedule front loading
South Carolina to RFK oh I mean it's the
first in nation primary and caucus
status is out that's done we're talking
about a a culture a Heritage that went
on for years is a reason why they Joe
Biden state is South Carolina that's his
solid early State
um contest and they front loaded it on
the schedule something that nobody would
ever think they would do oh they voted
early they moved it on the calendar
so they they Iowa it no longer is the
first in the nation contest in New
Hampshire is no longer the First Nation
primary so it's a big move they did that
intentionally or assumedly because to do
it before RFK could even campaign they
want to get the vote Yes they wanted
they wanted Joe Biden to have a win
right away and in small states are
cheaper to compete in let me let me pull
up this point we got 538 right here this
is the Democratic primary polls even
though there probably isn't going to be
one but this is interesting they've got
Kennedy in second place with 15 this is
McLaughlin Associates ABC News in the
Washington Post doesn't have uh Kennedy
of Biden versus Harris which is really
interesting don't know why they would do
that Biden beats Harris by 30 points wow
and then we have Harris ax with Kennedy
at 20 and a second poll at 16. we have
Emerson with Kennedy at 14. yoga with
Kennedy at seven and Rasmussen with
Kennedy at 25. University of New
Hampshire for the primary in New
Hampshire has Kennedy at nine uh then
you've got 19 15 14 as the remaining
polls all of these polls show Kennedy in
second place in the double digits so
about 14 15 seems reasonable for for
Kennedy we were at 15 last time our last
Paul last but we're about to do another
National we tried to do one a month he
was at 15. I hope he runs yeah it would
just be the most hilarious thing in the
world if Trump gets 43 nationally and
then wins it kind of reminds me it was a
felony
it reminds me with 91 when Bernie
Sanders in 2016 was getting pushed out
by Hillary and the DNC and he didn't go
independent now RFK is going independent
I thought at the time Bernie was going
to kowtow to the DNC and then they were
going to win but they didn't win so I I
my projection ability is like whacked
since 2016. I thought for sure the Deep
state was taking it and and for Trump to
come out on top was shocking so maybe
that can happen again it's funny that
all these people were crying because the
Deep State didn't win in 2016. like
those videos of all the Democrats crying
it's like oh no the CIA lost an election
the raincoat girl remember no I still
see the picture yeah
it's just insane what are you screaming
for what do you care what these people
are insane
but I guess whatever I I don't know what
happened in their lives where they
really thought that Trump was the
apocalypse you know right now the
Democrats are arresting lawyers they're
arresting protesters on on putting them
on 20 years they're uh arresting their
political opposition yep and they're
just like this is fine I think bro if
anyone has a right they don't know they
don't even want to admit that it's
happening most of my friends that are
that are left-leaning or that that are
come from like the music industry or
whatever they don't admit that or they
they refuse to acknowledge that there
are political persecutions they're like
oh well it's fine because it's Trump or
well they did this or they did that and
the spirit of the law the intent of the
law is totally irrelevant to them it's
just oh the government said they did
something wrong I don't like those
people so the government must be right
it is totally un like the unthinking
completely knee-jerk gut react excuse me
so
man it's disturbing stuff unimpeded I
think
RFK goes independent states votes away
from decrepit Joe Biden Democrats lose
Trump wins but I don't see an unimpeded
course I mean hold on with with uh with
if he runs an independent and he really
does get 14 let's say 15 right now of
the democratic vote so this means that
the correlation what will the
correlation be to the to the general
vote like seven percent six percent uh
well that depends on turnout the
Republic the electorate is getting more
Republican so once upon a time it would
be D plus three in 2016 something like
that uh 2020 was even R plus one so wow
yeah it's in the presidential election
yeah and and this is something that's
big and people have to talk about it the
higher the turnout the more Republican
the electorates are going to be now uh
that is for the first time in my life
I've never seen that before it always
was Republicans biting their fingernails
hoping that young people don't vote you
know non-white but it's not going to be
two to one it's not going to be like
five percent it's probably gonna be
around half to maybe like 45 yeah yeah I
mean so so a little less than half if if
RFK is pulling on the Democrat side
around 15. in the general election he
might pull about six seven points away
from Joe Biden yeah let's say the 38 40
of the electorate you know something
there you go yeah so so maybe six
percent six percent not quite a third
but a little bit more uh look at this so
I pulled up the 1992 election Bill
Clinton 43 percent
and the funny thing is were people I I'm
I'm asking this legitimately were people
complaining that he did not get the
majority
you mean back then yeah
oh absolutely because right now they're
all like Republican Trump won without
getting uh you know in 2016 he didn't
get the popular vote oh geez okay well
imagine what's going to happen if RFK
runs splits the Democratic vote and
Trump wins with 43 this goes and there
was a poll the other day about
abolishing the Electoral College same
thing with this it goes back and forth
depending on who is at the you know the
butt end of the stick right so in 2000
Bush won but he lost a popular vote
Democrats wanted to abolish the the
Electoral College in 04
um it looked like Bush would win the
popular vote then they wanted to keep
the Electoral College I mean it just
goes back and forth no matter who and
Gallup has been doing that for years uh
that's why when something's in place
like that it shouldn't be up for
National referendum so I hate those
polls they're totally irrelevant who
cares if somebody supports the Electoral
College or not there's a reason for it
we don't want a civil war upheaval let's
keep it you know so
um this can happen again though so I'm
glad you pulled that up because I tell
people this when we're looking at
Trump's write and vote people who are
voting for Trump in the primary say if
the man is not nominated I will either
write his name in some space on the
ballad or I will not vote and it's 30
plus percent do those accounts those
write-ins how if so you won't you won't
see them that night
they won't count them that night yes
eventually
Let's uh let's I want to pull up these
tweets from Mike cernovich talking about
what happens when we lose in 2024. now I
certainly think Mike is a bit
um what's the right word these tweets
are very very very serious I believe
they may be a bit aggressive but I think
the spirit of them is correct now that
I've given you that warning you'll
understand when I read them for you
Mike turnovich tweeted
when we lose in 2024 I'll be hunted down
and murdered by the regime have already
had this talk with my family all these
goober conservatives think they'll be
okay they won't look up the Bolshevik
Revolution Y'all Gonna Be imprisoned and
you people have no clue
he was quote tweeting uh himself he said
in this tweet showing these older tweets
as I tend to be ahead years usually on
subjects people attack me and then years
later copy my swag now I'll tell you the
future 2024 is total defeat the RNC
isn't even running ads on X let alone
doing other voter registration at scale
he then said when we lose he'll be
hunted down and then he added this if
you're a conservative with a large
platform have you talked to your family
about how you're going to be framed for
a crime to be killed in 2024 if Biden
wins if you think this is hyperbole you
have not been paying attention 2024 is
life or death it's time to understand
well
I'm gonna just show you Elijah Shafer he
responded saying I've already begun
taking precautions I'm International for
a reason I find that uh to be a very
interesting response from Mr Schaefer
and uh while I do think Mike's tweets
may be a bit aggressive
it's not so people misunderstand these
conversations because their view of the
world is based on the movie and in
movies what happens is the evil dictator
Supreme Emperor takes power and then
appears in a in a ghastly image of the
hood and goes Execute Order 66 and then
all of a sudden all the good guys are
just purged from existence that's not
really how it happens
um which you need to understand about
this stuff is okay so a tech
entrepreneur in Baltimore was just
beaten to death raped and murdered in
her own home and the man who did it was
known to the police because only a few
days earlier he had beaten tortured and
raped uh a woman in front of her her
boyfriend and then set them both on fire
I say these things because understand
that was for no reason
when Mike cernovich says when we lose
these things will happen perhaps
a bit aggressive as I stated because you
know we don't know the time frame for
kind of extremism will be
but there are several things you need to
understand one
we've got Chas chop already happening
we've got occupations already happening
around the country these things don't
happen overnight if you look to the
American Revolution the Boston Tea Party
and the Boston Massacre were years apart
Lexington Concord was 11 years at the
start of the revolutionary period the
bat like the actual start of the
Revolutionary War took 11 years from the
start of the period we determined to be
revolutionary
you get Chas chop in a matter of a
couple years you have autonomous zones
we currently have stop cop City right
now in Georgia where hundreds of people
went out and staged these acts of
violence we have a hundred people in
Philadelphia ransacking stores in total
disregard for the law there are that
that's social breakdown and social
disorder
what what I think would happen in the
immediate is I'll just put it this way
Mike cernovich is not wrong I don't
think he'll be hunted down and murdered
I think he'll be Julian Assange
people like Mike cernovich who pose a
threat to the established order of the
military-industrial complex and the
neoconservative neolib military agenda
whatever you want to call it uh you'll
get Julian Assange meaning they're going
to accuse you like Russell Brand I would
not be surprised if Russell Brand ends
up getting convicted they've already
found Donald Trump civilly liable for
the most psychotic rape story imaginable
they've already ordered the dissolution
of Trump's companies and he's facing 91
indictments now that's Trump but people
keep saying this thing where it's like
I'll be okay well Aaron danielson's not
okay he took two to the chest he's no
longer around so
perhaps again a bit aggressive because I
don't know if it's effective messaging
to say they're going to kill you ah
they're screaming oh well look guys the
reality is dark days are in front of us
how long this period takes we don't know
I actually don't think we're facing
total defeat in 2024. I I disagree with
Mike on this I respect his opinion I
think he's very smart I think he does
see ahead better than most but I I do
see a a possibility for victory in 2024
especially now that RFK is running this
changes the game substantially but just
understand
even if Trump does win it doesn't mean
whatever is happening in this country
ends when you have far left extremists
storming government property firebombing
things when it is the norm for them to
go on social media and and threaten
people with death and the reason why we
bring the story up first is because the
next door we're talking about is the guy
who threatened to blow up Andy knows
speaking event was arrested so they're
they're still Law and Order you know a
little bit social order is breaking down
when you look at San Francisco when you
look at Philadelphia when you look at
Chicago New York these flash mobs all
over the place that shows social order
breakdown and understand this
what do you think the government does
when social order breaks down do you
think that the government will come
protect you when you are under attack by
violent mobs of Lawless Riders
look only to 2020 when in the there are
two big stories a woman was in her car
surrounded by rioters screaming and
banging on her car and she called 9-1-1
and they said what do you want us to do
and she goes they're attacking me what
do I do I have my daughter in the car
and they're like ma'am what do you want
us to do
good luck another guy in his apartment
said that people were fighting in his
Lobby and the riding was get there and
he was told sir the city is under attack
what would you have us do
I love the writing of the game Fallout
3. you guys I think you're all familiar
with it at this point I talk about it a
lot the so for those that are familiar
Fallout video game I know it's fiction
but it's it's written by humans who are
are looking at what happens around the
world and what they think may occur
the video game is about a nuclear
Annihilation nuclear war wipes out the
world and then everyone goes into vaults
simplified version the government
becomes something called The Enclave the
remnants of United States government and
you know what they do they they shoot
and kill you in the game and this is I
think correct writing on the part of the
game developers the US government will
seek to preserve itself and you are in
the way so when we begin seeing
non-citizens being shipped into Staten
Island what do the police do beat and
arrest the residents of Staten Island
they seek to preserve themselves by any
means necessary and you are in the way
so what Mike is saying and my concerns
are more so it's not that Biden will get
reelected and Order uh order the police
to Execute order 66. it's that they're
gonna say circle the wagons around
government and and
Destroy in any any way possible anyone
who threatens us
if you want to know what's going to
happen you can look to what happened in
the cultural revolution in China
there is ample examples of what happens
when the government has a a change of
what the fundamental principles that
government stands for means and the way
that the population reacts and the way
that the government reacts we saw in
2020 a whole lot of rioting and a whole
lot of stuff going on and the police
could not and maybe they could have but
they refused to do anything about it
I don't see any reason why if there is
some other type of civil unrest like
that how the police or the the
government would would behave any
different definitely you I would hope
that they would see the mistake they
made in 2020 by letting it get out of
hand they've been not stopping it on day
two it didn't get out of hand to them
they got what they wanted in fact it
worked perfectly what I'm wondering is
because you were saying I think Tim
mentioned it's like a dissolution of
order in the system but what I
definitely see is a rise of organized
crime in the system these people that
are organizing on Facebook chats
wherever signal they're organizing flash
mobs they're organizing and it's like
not one organization it's a lot of
little organizations but it's a new type
of organized crime that needs to be
dealt with and it's maybe that the
government doesn't know how to deal with
it quite yet I mean they got their spy
Tech but it's just so disparate it's
hard to see it coming you've got nine
poor kids in Philadelphia that want to
get on a signal chat and decide to go
break into a Best Buy at nine o'clock
like you can't how does the government
so so it might be that they are
unequipped it worst case scenario
they're they're complicit that's what
happened that's what I fear the most
because if if the government Gets behind
organized crime then you're looking at a
cultural revolution that's like what it
is
um hopefully there they want to stomp it
out as much as the citizens do and
they're just looking for a time to place
yeah he he mentions the Bolshevik in the
Tweet you just mentioned the cultural
all of these have in common a plan for
different tiers in society right so the
average normal you know normal person
that's a problem would be dealt with a
lot differently right maybe they just
leave that to the flash mobs maybe that
they leave that to the activists in the
extremist uh but people like cernovich
and maybe even some of us you know I
mean seriously uh that would be
different you know the Julian Assange
treatment
lawfare when it can be done you know I
know people who um
have been indicted in Georgia we're this
close to being indicted in Georgia uh so
they're there but I guess that that
matters what role are you playing and
how influential are you and opposing
something that they don't like I do just
want to bring up this 2024's total
defeat I don't know if he's using
reverse psychology there or what but
he's right about the RNC not doing
enough so as a pollster I look at this
and I say they're indicting Trump
because he is
improve so much with certain groups that
Republicans are not supposed to win they
know that and they're looking at that
and they're saying what up what other
choice do I have I might as well because
if this man gets back in it may be me on
the Block
um still
the RNC is way behind in infrastructure
they should have done much better in 22
and didn't because they still don't
really understand what they're up
against
and even watching because I I know about
this even watching some of them trying
to get it together and trying to deal
with ballot harvesting uh it's a messiah
complex on the right everyone wants to
be the hero they're not working together
like Democrats work together well I
highlighted this in a segment where I
was talking about Democrats going full
communist because they're cheering for
the ruling against Trump's businesses
where the judge basically banged the
gavel summary judgment no more Trump
organization and I showed this voting uh
chart
of the social scale and the economic
scale Trump's voters are anti-woke but
spread out between the left and the
right Trump even has Communists to
support him like I don't mean like um
the ideological Communists of the woke I
mean people who believe in very far left
Progressive economic systems of
government control
they all he has very few actually
laissez-faire capitalists interestingly
but they're very it's it's the cluster
is in the center doesn't surprise me the
Democrat block is clustered entirely in
the far left Social and economic area
which means they mostly just March in
lockstep not completely there there are
Democrats reaching up into the less woke
area but the cluster may be the
plurality large Pro or majority is all
hyper concentrated in one Circle Ultra
woke as far left as possible in both
economic and social again Trump's base
was anti-woke opposing the social left
but spread out economic in terms of
Economic Policy which explains shows
like this
well you know I'll just jump in again
um
but I I have to point out again that
they know that they're starting to see
that so you know Obama's old pollster uh
you know he puts out a poll last last
month and he's having a meltdown over it
and of course they're all trying to make
themselves feel better so on top of that
they're trying to see how some of the
people on different ends of that
Spectrum react if you ask things like
well what if he's convicted of you know
one felony two right they're just trying
to get some good news out of it and when
all said and done a lot of these people
I don't think are gonna care when they
are looking at maybe they're not saying
it out loud like cernovich is saying it
but I do feel like listening to people
that we interview all the time
a lot of people are are where cernovich
is here even being hyperbolic and if you
notice who is
well he's saying hyperbole yeah right
right he even if you look at who is most
angry at these responses or think he's
being hyperbolic it's a certain group
and I don't know who watched it or who
didn't but Bill O'Reilly was interviewed
by Tucker the other day
and Tucker said well what's going to
happen here is Trump going to be elected
from prison or what would happen if he
is elected and Bill O'Reilly just kind
of still even now
just dismiss the idea that Donald Trump
could be convicted or would be convicted
and sent the person oh worst case
scenario is going to be in house arrest
in the white house and I just feel like
this is a real big generational divide
on this that uh there are still some
older people who haven't seen it but
again in in the primary and I can say
this from pulling the primary Trump's
big lead really started to happen when
older voters couldn't believe that he
really was indicted they didn't think it
would happen I want to highlight just
real quick this article this is from the
rap from July 1st 2020. Dilbert crater
Scott Adams says Republicans will be
hunted if Biden wins election there's a
good chance you will be dead within the
year Adam says definitely hyperbolic
okay no within the year you are not dead
only Aaron Danielson was a few months
later so my point here is and I'm being
somewhat of a dick when I say that is
that he was he was he was actually
fairly correct despite being hyperbolic
Scott Adams said you'll be haunted and
then a few months later they just walked
into the student shot him for being a
trump supporter nothing just put two in
his chest
we have not seen that repeated
on a great scale so consider that right
and also consider would you have heard
this news were it not for the internet
so I want to make sure people understand
that uh bad things happen and you need
to balance the is this a one-off of
Portland being a crazy Bleeding Kansas
type state
or is it really as bad well look Scott
Adams says there's a good chance he'll
be done within the year okay dude yeah
it's been three years since I got
elected we're all here we're all still
working so I'll say something similar to
Mike cernovich I do think alarm is
warranted but
perhaps a bit aggressive gentleman
perhaps a bit aggressive right yeah for
sure the way he phrased it too like I
don't have to tweet in front of me
anymore you are going to like talking to
me saying we are like don't pull me into
your little muck there Mike I get what
you're saying but I'm not part of your
group there no but they go out there it
doesn't yeah don't don't scare try and
scare me into making a point and get me
to follow you it's junk it it's I think
that the point really is because of the
way that the left has framed the the
quote-unquote sides anyone that's not on
their team is somehow on the other team
it's the basket of deplorables comment
that Clinton made if you do not fall in
line and you have the if you have the
wrong politics and that doesn't mean
Trump's politics that means not their
politics then you are on the outside and
you are just as liable to be thrown into
the group of the bad guys as anyone
else's it doesn't matter if you're a
Maga person or you're like
one of the the free Staters up in New
Hampshire that are Libertarians or or
whatever if you are not on board with
their project then you have the wrong
politics there is the the thing about
political correctness is there is the
correct politics and that means
everything else that is not that is
incorrect so it doesn't matter what your
politics are all it Matt all that
matters is your politics are not theirs
so it's you can't you don't you don't
get to walk away from it in a
revolutionary period a communist
revolutionary period it is not the
revolutionaries who are killed first
that's
After the Revolution they begin purging
revolutionaries
the so in terms of if we are undergoing
something akin to what cernovich and
Scott Adams have described
so to understand the context using this
room as an example Ian you are their
first Target
you are a collaborator and you are uh uh
you you have less defenses so when it
when it comes to a rogue spear type
period they're going to be looking for
people who they view as collaborators
who don't have the means to defend
themselves look at it this way Spanish
Civil War style you've got people who
are living in the neighborhood that
there's where there's a conflict between
the nationalists uh like the Republicans
and the Communists or whatever the
factions were fascist Republicans call
whatever you want that uh and so can
they go into the territory that is
militarized and fortified by their
political opposition no they can't but
what about the collaborator who lives
down the street some that so that's I'm
not saying you literally I'm saying in
in the context of what this is you've
got uh
there there will be someone who is known
to have spoken out and said you guys are
wrong this revolution shouldn't happen
I'm friends with those guys
in the in the revolutionary period those
are the people that get gulagged and
purged the people like in this instance
me or Phil are the ones in the Fortified
areas they can't get to I'm speaking
figuratively not literally so in terms
of can the government come and start
arresting people and chargeable they are
and there's a reason why when it came to
January 6 there are certain high profile
people who are targeted yeah certain
high profile people who are not targeted
and certain and most people who were
targeted were low profile and no one
even knows their names
if the federal government were to indict
Alex Jones hey hold on they indicted
Owen Shroyer despite the fact they were
both part of the same event because Alex
Jones would create too big of a backlash
and they know hey if we drop a boulder
in this Lake it's going to wake
everybody up oh and Shroyer we can we
can we can mess with and it will be you
know moderately sized rock that will
cause a splash not too bad but all these
little Pebbles we can strip them all out
with no opposition
after they strip away the Pebbles then
they can go for the boulders So when you
say stuff to like Scott Adams you're
like don't say that don't don't put me
in your group your group no Santa Mike
cernovich well right either right and my
point is this but he didn't he didn't do
that to me overtly I'm just saying my
point is tweet right in my face their
tweets are definitely in my opinion a
bit over the top for sure I think
they're describing something genuine but
very alarmist in how they do it and it's
funny because everyone says that about
me when I describe Civil War and here I
am saying guys you know it's been three
years since Bonnie got elected we're
still alive okay uh there are a few
people who have died in a revolution
they're going for collaborators and
people who are unaligned and refuse to
stand behind a line because you're not
you're you're you're uh you have you
lack defense so it is not literally you
that's what I'm trying to say I'm saying
it's going to be the dude who's at work
and being like look man I'm keeping my
head down yeah they're gonna be like
look bro we've seen your Facebook okay
the group of trump supporters over there
they got they've fortified themselves
they have a parallel economy you you're
fired so again I'm clarifying I mean
this all figuratively what I think will
end up happening is there's going to be
a dude working at a factory and they're
going to be all going Democrat Democrat
Democrat and all these conservative
Trump supporters are building a parallel
economy forming companies forming jobs
downloading apps like Public Square so
that they can keep working and working
in the film industry in the music
industry and then these guys who are
working uh at these companies where
they're just like look if I just don't
say anything nah the boss going to come
and they're going to be like so uh you
went into a meeting yesterday with Janet
by yourself it's like yeah she was
asking me about the TPS reports I'm like
yeah
um you're being accused of sexual
assault so we're going to have to escort
you out of the building and things like
that so uh that is to say quite
literally you work at Tim guest you're
fine I'm saying these people who think
that they're going to say nothing and
I'm not involved with you don't don't
rope me with you if I stay away from
these guys I'll be safe no you're the
first ones to get fired first ones to
lose your job you're the collaborators
you're the the you're the the opposition
you know I'm listening to you see this
and give these examples though and maybe
it's not widespread it's not it's not
yet but I'm thinking about after January
6th I had uh
I got I got these military documents and
what they were saying was we're going to
start to look through people in your
company
um we're gonna start to look through
their their Facebooks and their social
posts and if they liked something from
these groups uh then obviously they were
going to do something discipline them or
something like that that's within the
military it wasn't widespread yet in the
populace but guess it was in there the
problem is you know those groups I want
to uh so I don't know what happened to
those people but they had it there it
was the Marine Corps by the way I want
to publish them on Twitter I want to
jump to this next tweet from Mike
cernovich so uh let's fresh segment let
me just uh for those are just tuning in
cernovich has a series of tweets that
are similar in essence to what Scott
Adams had said in the last election that
you know that that he believes uh
certain believes he'll be hunted
down and killed in 2020 after 2024 if
you know if we lose he says if you're
conservative of the large platform have
you talked to your family about how
you're going to be framed for a crime he
quote tweeted this he says 2024 is life
or death and he quotes we did saying
John Eastman facing disbarment for a
legal memo on an open constitutional law
issue Trump judge said Mar-A-Lago only
worth 18 million dollars Michigan
elderly Republicans indicted Georgia
fake RICO case scotus is the only stop
Gap once that's gone there's no law I'm
not even convinced scotus is because
when it came to Texas V Pennsylvania in
2020 scotus said we are too cowardly to
answer a question of original on
original jurisdiction which is insane
they have to and they didn't I believe
Thomas and Leto are correct I highlight
this to make the point
while cernovich and Scott Adams sang
It's life or death may have been
hyperbolic then maybe now cernovich says
it's not hyperbolic and these are all
goober conservatives I don't think so he
does point out something very important
in this tweet Michigan elderly
Republicans were indicted
it is not going to be
Execute Order 66 as I stated in the
previous segment it is going to be
you are you commit a fraud that's right
uh yeah we we uh we think you committed
fraud um so you're under arrest
elderly Republicans were were tasked
we're electors we're asked to sign
documents in the event lawsuits were won
they would require these documents it is
a normal constitutional procedure
Michigan indicted them and they are
facing the rest of their lives in prison
overdoing what they are constitutionally
requested to do they'll use the IRS oh
hands down they are Obama already did it
yeah Obama went after uh what tea party
groups that's right yep so it's it's
crazy to me that people are like
cernovich is out of his mind okay again
like I don't know about you just being
dead right away but 10 years ago Obama
used the IRS to Target his political
opponents where they are now look where
we are they're arresting lawyers you
know they're they're arresting lawyers
the judge a judge in New York on summary
judgment bang the gavlin said the Trump
organization is to be dissolved and then
sanctioned the lawyers for arguing
it's there's no the system already is is
fractured and busted up yeah we see it
like we were talking earlier about in
1992 with like I don't know we talk
about Rodney King earlier in the week
but like just the chaos and the things
that have happened that didn't get
televised but now like anything any guy
can tweet out eight things that have
happened Aaron Danielson we talked about
a million times like that probably
wouldn't even got National media
attention or maybe it would have but
like maybe it may not have gotten
National media so I agree this could be
an example of just taking these things
and blowing them out of proportion but I
think the Trump indictments are just
beyond the pale like that is it's
history yeah it is it is one of the most
egregious violations of of this
country's values laws Norms rules the
Constitution and it is one of the most
if not the most significant thing that
has happened to this country since its
founding right you can talk about the
Civil War and then I would say Okay
perhaps we can have a conversation about
the Civil War that when Abraham Lincoln
was trying to he tried to I don't think
he did actually in a sitting Supreme
Court Justice but this was secession and
then conflict
so
right now this could be on par with
these moves that led to 1865. it's like
a we're in a different country and
literally like the same name but because
like someone in in Tacoma Washington
will be online talking to their best
friend in England and they're they don't
have any friends in Tacoma because
they're online so it's like a different
world a different reality this country
now 1861 I should have said you know
it's like we're a different country
that's the difference between this
country
and other countries or has been that we
don't beat each other political
opposition uh in the juror box we beat
them in The Ballot Box that's really you
know something that one of the only
things that really does or did separate
us that's not happening now that's the
real difference in the major uh shift
and
you know I it people ask me how is this
going to impact the election I think
it's just a matter of it's a fight of
it's a fight between Wills it's a matter
of resolve and you're gonna get hit with
something new every day they want to
remove them from the ballot here Andrew
it's just brought up the Civil War the
last time Democrats removed a candidate
from The Ballad
was Abraham Lincoln in 1860. that's it
it's really the only time I can even
recall it being done They removed him
from the bout in southern states I have
removed him from the and here's the
funny thing what they're trying or want
to do now is remove Trump from the
ballot in blue states that he would
otherwise have very little prayer in
winning anyway that's what happened to
Lincoln and he still won but uh there
are four candidates that's right the
vote was split similarities are sick man
what if it's Cornell West parallels RFK
Biden Trump giving Trump 37 38 but
enough to win yeah yeah and then they
take his name off the ballot Six States
right this is crazy because there could
be and that's why you saw it in Colorado
in a situation like 16
when we had disaffected voters going to
you know Gary Johnson Jill Stein
Colorado got close there Tim got way
closer than it should have been so did
New Mexico what people need to
understand is that Strauss how
generational theory is not this profound
Discovery it's just the writer's cycle
for Earth simulation seasons one two
three and four right season one the
American Revolution season two the Civil
War season three World War World at War
they had to spice thing up spice things
up it wasn't just enough for America to
be fighting and so now we're going for
how about interdimensional no Civil War
and World War Three
all at the same time every time
something crazy new happens that is like
a we passed this Rubicon we we crossed
this line it does seem to be aliens
they're trying it but the water's too
hot they keep pulling their toe out it's
just people don't buy it but it used to
be and you were kind of maybe you're
alluding this but I was thinking about
it where you're talking that it you'd
get the presidential vote whether you
hated the guy or like the guy you'd vote
it didn't really matter like yeah your
commanders the commander but Congress
runs the show it doesn't really matter
and and so like let's all enjoy life as
Americans that's what we get to do
together you you I'm sure you know about
voter turnout in the early days of this
country right
what the voter turnout percentages were
I mean I'll have them on top of my head
uh like they were 10 yeah they were they
were abysmal until Jacksonian Democracy
which started to ramp it up uh which
reached around like 20 20 some odd
percent yeah which makes sense because
then when women suffrage happened it
basically doubled so women started
voting what did Jackson do that enticed
voters
one man one vote you have no
representation and then there's actually
a lot of parallels to Trump as well and
he loves Trump loves Jackson
um you know he won too early like Trump
which I think you could argue Trump came
in and I I mean I remember in 16 saying
to people you know the election of one
man a revolution does not make here
there are still a bunch of cheese
Republicans in the in the senate in the
house they're you know this is not gonna
go how a lot of people think it's gonna
go that happened to Jackson and uh the
The Establishment status quo came Adam
and he had to regroup and he and this is
something Donald Trump still isn't I
don't at least not yet I have not seen
him learn he was just run with his own
slate of candidates look at what is
going on right now with this death fight
with the the CR the continuing
resolution he wants them to defund the
law fair political offer that that's
just not gonna happen with the the
current bunch of uh cowards I mean yeah
you know that are in Congress it's not
going to happen we know who these people
are we know the talent that's in these
same districts go after them Trump
should be running the America first
ticket not the Republican ticket you
know not he should be running the
America first ticket and if you're for
me in Texas 12 you vote for John O'Shea
if you're for me you vote for Matt gates
in Florida one if you're for me that is
uh that benefited a lot of bad people in
2016. Trump always gave more than he got
from the traditional GOP Coalition and
he draw he drug a bunch of losers over
the Finish Line who would then stick a
knife right in his back so this is
something he's got I know he's you know
the guy's busy but law Affair he's
trying to run for president it's you're
going to repeat 2016 and 17 all over
again if you don't do this
so like where Lindsey Graham he he said
everybody vote for Lindsey Graham and
they did anyone in the big mistake okay
you know so he should you're saying he
should specifically like should he
should he denounce certain people that
he has no because you don't want to make
enemies yet like there's nothing you can
do about Lindsey Graham and plus you
want to win South Carolina you don't
want to lose
um there is up country super
conservative South Carolina and then
there's Horry County you know and other
places around Charleston you don't want
to lose that so you don't pick fights
with people you can't remove but
um there are I mean they're they're
allies and congressmen are up every two
years and we know who the Senators are
and one I just mentioned Texas 12 this
is a woman
Who is the uh Appropriations Committee
so this is relevant to right now I think
Matt Gates was just on your show yeah a
couple days making a deal about this
okay Granger
made a deal with Trump she had Chris
Putnam on her butt and Putnam was in the
lead and she said you know I need the
president's help for his endorsement he
said I need your help on impeachment she
he gave her the endorsement she defeated
Chris Putnam when he needed her support
in the impeachment hearing and the vote
she went home pretended she was sick and
refused to vote by proxy I mean this is
the kind of spineless and it's not even
spineless in that case it's just
backstabbing it's treachery you know and
you're not going to affect meaningful
change with that kind of treachery if I
told people that there are maybe three
to five tops and I think I'm being
generous at five solid Republicans in
the U.S Senate out of all of them you
mean I wonder how many would be
surprised Matt Gates had to fight tooth
and nail to defeat that spending bill
for Ukraine finally it was that was a
big Turning Point 119 Republicans voted
against it uh I think 102 something
voted for it but against had more than
not that's a big deal because that
doesn't happen the house Republican
conference is probably 85 to 90 percent
coward I may even be being generous with
that they're not really what they claim
to be John Duarte out in California 13
ran on border security I'm super trumpy
and by the way I need migrant workers so
I want to keep the Border open he voted
against the uh the the trans Bill the
other day I mean these people say one
thing completely do another when they
get in there and this is a uniquely
Republican problem you will not see this
on the Democratic side when was the last
time Tim you saw a Democrat promise
something right that's a liberal
um you know I I don't want to say yeah
liberal Orthodoxy and then get to
Congress and stab their voters in the
back AOC did it
with what famously with Israel right
away yeah no and they were all the
progressives were like whoa whoa she's
taking the establishment deadline now
and yeah I mean on like you know and
that's that that's peripheral compared
to like trade or immigration is for
Republicans you know so you know
seriously you know um I just I just
don't think their words are worth
anything yeah they should be Publishers
Democrats or Republicans there's like
seven Republicans where I'm kind of like
yeah yeah maybe maybe like if they were
like I'll endorse you but then you'll
vote for me on that and they need to put
it in writing or they need to put it
into a smart contract so it triggers
automatically they don't get to to
resend their their agreement but would
that be like you know
Todd sawicki uh they use had great
research on this like the whole system
relies on that kind of a trust you know
it is a status quo I'll scratch your
back you scratch mine uh but when it's
like complete betrayal you know then the
whole thing's just there's no benefit
for them to to sign some something like
a smart contract that automatically
executes because the the possibility of
changing is what gives them leverage to
leverage one side against the other so
they'll go ahead and they'll say yes I
promise to do this but then they'll go
and talk behind closed doors to their
the people that'll give them donations
or whatever and say well you know we'll
do this and blah blah that's what
Hillary Hillary Clinton came out and
said that when you when she said you
have your public position and then your
private position she specifically
articulated it just like that you have a
public position and then you have a
private position
the duplicity is part of the system it's
part of it's part and parcel of the
system it's what they use
to to get one side to play against the
other so the the idea that that they
would ever agree to Smart contracts
where they say yes I'm going to do this
and then when it happens it triggers and
Etc it won't happen because then they
don't have the the ability to to
basically the ability to lie it's just
like when when you say oh you know we
should we should get uh we should get
um term limits for people in in Congress
and et cetera et cetera they're never
going to vote for that let me let me uh
talk about politics of scale so so
people can understand why politicians
literally don't care about you why
Hillary Clinton never cared about gay
marriage but claim to support and then
privately said she was opposed to it
because it doesn't matter to her the
people who are running the country are
simply thinking about how do I maintain
maximum power and they view themselves
as the American people are it's like an
ant farm or a chicken coop I like using
the chicken coop and algae they need
more eggs to have a an egg fight with
people in China and they don't care that
much about the chickens I mean they
don't want the chickens to die but when
a chicken dies they're like well let's
get another one right whatever so let me
explain something about it so everyone
can understand I can explain it in the
best way that I can relative to uh my
business
when you start a show or a coffee shop
or anything
and your business is directly associated
with a small community maybe you make
bagels and you sell them uh to the
public you know that you have about a
thousand regular customers and then you
have maybe a uh maybe like 2 000 people
who come and go that you'll never see
before on average they'll visit your
shop one time never come back 3 000
people you know why Jim didn't show up
today oh he comes in every morning gets
an orange juice and gets a bagel with
cream cheese and then one day doesn't
show up and you're like wonder where he
is next day he shows up and he's like ah
you know I had something happened with
the dog a special circumstance occurred
as your business gets bigger you start
to notice that the weather has profound
impacts whereas some things probably
don't matter to the individual partaking
them it has a tremendous impact in the
back end of a larger scale business that
is to say
to what degree does winter does summer
and does rain affect a YouTube channel
now most people who are fans of the show
watch the show all the time but one
person will simply say
you know what it's really nice this this
Friday night I'm gonna go and hang out
with my friends I'll catch Tim cast IRL
later but guess what this is replicated
by three to seven percent of our viewer
base
I cannot address the single individual
who doesn't who doesn't shop for
whatever reason and most people probably
think this one person not showing up
doesn't matter but in the back end when
you have a scale of a million plus
viewers
you you actually can see insane Trends
so this actually applies to what AI
tracks as well when it comes to health
and fitness and like you're you're like
when they're looking at blood like uh
your blood oxygenation and they can find
cancer we actually see crazy things in
our data that you wouldn't notice unless
you have millions of viewers
and then you're like nothing you can do
about it it's it's hard to get super uh
I don't know it's kind of hard to
explain but the general idea is we can
see weather patterns in viewership and
then I can correlate oh viewership was
down in this region I bet it was sunny
out and 65 degrees and then sure enough
we can see that's right in Southern
California it was a beautiful day no
that's obvious oh what's that viewership
was really high today I bet it rained
and then we checked yup rained more
people watch so when you're in
government relate these things you are
thinking about we want more oil more oil
means more money more money means more
power more power means we control more
regions they are not thinking about you
as a human being and your child so when
it comes to issues of like why do they
want to sterilize kids why do they want
to abort kids because they don't care
about you as an individual your life is
meaningless they're looking for a seven
percent return on their investment
Nothing Else Matters they're looking at
their chicken coop and saying this new
feed is going to kill off 20 of the
chickens but they're going to lay twice
as many eggs so we're actually getting
more eggs because 20 less chickens means
20 less eggs but for the chickens that
survive we're getting two times the eggs
so this is even better they don't care
about you this is how government at
scale works they will sacrifice you your
individual pattern of behaviors is
meaningless to them and they will just
simply maximize economic output to the
detriment of large swaths of the
population
that being said
Fair Point man when Matt Gates is here
he said something very important that I
help people understand
we were all laughing and cheering for a
government shutdown we as as fans of
Matt Gates and his work in congress not
constituents in Florida but fans of the
work he does
I was like this is fantastic here's a
guy who's sticking it to the government
it's going to cause a shutdown guess
what I don't care if the government
shuts down doesn't hurt me guess what
disabled veterans very scared so when
you're Matt Gates and you know you have
to stop this Omnibus spending trash
but it could mean a government shutdown
and then comes a knock on your door and
there is a disabled veteran and he says
please don't take my paycheck from me I
have given everything what more Mustang
he's got him there and then and then
Matt has to say my friend
I understand and I'm sorry
we have to do this but as a politician
the the confrontations that you'll
experience the circumstances are going
to be
do the right thing
but no matter what you do you're going
to piss somebody off and do we as people
who want to solve the problem of Omnibus
spending want to sacrifice the
well-being of our disabled veterans to
get there that's a that's a very
difficult question isn't it so you'll
end up with politicians most of them
don't care at all they're simply asking
themselves how many disabled veterans
are going to lose their money and how
will that affect my numbers come
November that's what they're thinking
because November's in the short term
right right so that Matt Gates and you
know bless him for it he's thinking
guess what you're not gonna have a check
at all when this debt bomb blows right
and guaranteed all of these dirtbags are
going to be pretending they were right
up shoulder to shoulder fighting with
Matt Gates when that happens I mean if
we could fast forward guys if something
doesn't change and we could fast forward
I don't know how long it's going to be
nobody does but we could fast forward to
the future when we have to really uh be
held accountable for this you're gonna
recklessness you're gonna You're Gonna
Hear members of Congress go when get
Matt Gates and I was fighting against
this
totally everybody everybody
uh even Democrats even Democrats you
know if it wasn't for the Republicans
trying to give tax cuts to the wealthy
we would have had this under control
um and that's the tragic part about it
because oh you know that we can't can we
grow our way out of this problem anymore
you know maybe under Trump when uh we
were seeing a period Revenue was coming
in from the tax cuts and job act and it
was starting to rise because we were in
that Goldilocks zone of corporate tax
rates and then we were going at three
percent or more if covid didn't hit that
was our window
the windows closed we need a new fuel
source now oil is too expensive and
heavy we need hydrogen fuel if we can
transform our economy into a new form of
productivity because money is not what
it's about it's money it's about
productivity what are we creating what
is the value of the things we are
creating
cheap Fuel and um I think graphene is a
building material you get the graphene
is the byproduct of the hydrogen
formation you actually make four dollars
and fifty cents for every kilogram of
hydrogen you produce new technology I
got to stop right there you're wrong I'm
sorry uh we need cold fusion
my real point is that you're actually
correct I'm just I'm never going I'm
just being pedantic I'm saying that
Beyond just hydrogen the uh nuclear
energy right now is a very very
important source of of energy for us
and this is all obviously like we as
chickens in the chicken coop I'm just
assuming that the information we've
collected and gathered being
disseminated is correct but they lie to
us all the time so it's hard to know
but they oppose nuclear energy despite
the fact that it's carbon neutral and it
has a massive I believe it's the highest
energy returned on energy invested that
means for every calorie of energy that
goes in you get I I can't remember what
it was I watched a documentary about it
was like 50 energy out from nuclear
whereas like oil is 30 and like solar is
like 0.7
for every calorie of energy going into
solar you actually get less output
granted it's improved dramatically the
thing about solar is more so
decentralizing the Grid in the event of
a military strike Cyber attack or
otherwise
um and also creating diversifying it's
diversifying but also that's why I use
it too the reason we got solar is not
because we're like we're going to be
good thirds of the Earth yeah I don't
think that's the case I think it's if
the power goes out we're good
right so nuclear energy is the first
step you're right about hydrogen but we
should start with nuclear power plants
you think so I like hydrogen because
it's um individuals can can use it and
they're carry it around with them and
put it in their car if we can make
hydrogen gasoline hybrid engines but but
for now the infrastructure for nuclear
exists and then we need to start
expanding the infrastructure for
hydrogen and for other materials
ultimately the point and I want to drill
this into every politician's head every
businessman's head the answer to our
economy the solution to our economy is
not in the economic it's not in the
money it's in the productivity of
devices and technology so yeah yeah and
and that's another tragedy of the
post-covet economy and and you know I
don't care what your party is Joe Biden
winning we started again to move away
from that and uh under Trump we went
back to good Purdue you know good Goods
producing uh productivity was obviously
increasing
it you can kind of get away too with
having it and I don't want to encourage
debt but if you make things the world
needs and you are the leader of that you
get grace period if your entire economy
which is uh you know uh your your
strength is based on the Petro dollar
and you're not making it enough it's too
expensive your debt's ridiculous uh then
that puts you in a bad way we may buy
ourselves some time being something that
somebody needs this is this honestly I
think the the more reasonable the more
likely reason that uh the US and Israel
teamed up on stux not to blow up the
Iranian centrifuges was not because
they're making nuclear weapons it's
because the West knew they were trying
to make nuclear power and create an
economy that wasn't functioning off of
oil I'll buy that for a dollar I really
will right and then the US was like the
Petro dollar is law don't make nuclear
energy yeah but they needed an excuse
for why they were attacking a foreign
country and it was they're building
nuclear weapons
sure let's jump to the story we got some
we got some big news
this is from timcast.com woman who
burned down Wyoming abortion clinic
sentenced to five years in prison Lorna
Roxanne green was given the minimum
possible sentence for the arson Laura
boxing green 22 a 22 year old this is
Gen Z received the minimum possible
sentence for the 2022 arson at
Wellspring Health Access in Casper
I'm sorry man look don't please please
we we don't do things like this you
should not do things like this we are
trying to avoid this we're trying to win
through the process by which the
founding fathers helped in Shrine I
understand a lot of people are here the
founding fathers fought and did a lot of
stuff it's like dude they also fought to
create a system where we could with the
Constitution the Bill of Rights solve
these problems without having to that
was the whole point right that was the
whole point right representation fight
again they didn't want to fight in the
first place and that's right quite
literally the fighting was because they
weren't being represented we now have a
a crumbling fractured system but still
an opportunity it is not it is not done
impossible so please that's why we
should not have done this but I bring
the story up because I have warned about
this
we have we've seen it before the attacks
on abortion clinics and we've had the
conversation on this show that when you
start seeing uh States say abortion to
the point of birth and other states say
no abortion at all Oklahoma and Colorado
sharing a border this is an
inevitability now again
people should not be doing this okay you
it needs to be handled by by a law
enforcement Arbiter to shut these things
down through the vote and that's what
you're getting in the in in the states
that are passing the laws and they're
doing it by the book let them let the
left overreact and let the law take care
of it because that's the that's the
process by which we have agreed we can
get these things done
however
um it pains me to say man I I hate to
say I told you so and I think we're
gonna see worse than this first of all
she's getting the minimum five years in
prison for burning down an abortion
clinic did she actually burn it down
well I mean I would assume if Cassandra
wrote it it burnt down did people get
hurt but she'd get murdered stuck inside
absolutely absolutely yeah I I don't
think anybody was hurt because uh that
would change
that that would change the sentence
sentencing guidelines all together yeah
so yeah burning down is a is is a direct
statement that means it would totally
destroy the building but I'm not
entirely sure burn it Into Obscurity
into unrecognizability
well once you have a gas tank gas
canister or something gasoline yes in
this building so of course this will
also be weaponized by The Establishment
by the uh Democrats in government
absolutely they'll use this as a tool
they're going to run these commercials
in 2024 as uh why you have to vote for
us they're going to say far right
extremists are doing this that or
otherwise
my point is not to bring that up my
point is simply to say people are on
edge and this stuff is happening but but
there is a better way to deal with this
issue there are very very uh strong
opinions on on both sides but
Republicans are not handling this issue
well at all they're not and they create
you know every once in a while there
needs to be a release valve in society
and public policy if something's not
going your way uh unfortunately can lead
to stuff like this Republicans know
where they have the country on abortion
and yet they just continuously overreach
I also want to make sure because this is
not just about Democrats it's the story
here from the post-millennial leader in
Richmond Democrat Party group arrested
after posting bomb threat against Andy
no in Virginia talk there's a big
difference between threatening someone
and then actually sneaking to a building
and setting on fire so I want to make
sure that's clear my point for this
segment is not to accuse one side of
being worse than the other these are two
anecdotes two extreme instances but it's
it's it's it's worrisome to see these
kinds of things happen
there's there's already heightened
political tensions and now we have the
like bro these are these are young
people and they are just ruining their
lives they've lost their minds the
firebomb lawyers and mental illness is a
big problem to him after the uh the
summer of 2020 I'll accuse one side of
being worse than the other side no no no
no I agree with that no I'm saying right
now with these two articles oh okay I'm
not here to be like aha but look what
they left it no obviously a threat is
not as bad as actually burning a
building down you know I'm highlighting
these things to say there is conflict in
this country and people say things like
we're not in a civil war and it's like
civil Strife Stephen Marsh describes it
as civil Strife it's the period before
Civil War it's like Bleeding Kansas
perhaps that's where we're at I think
Portland is absolutely in a Bleeding
Kansas State where businesses are
fleeing flash mobs are destroying
everything like
people are are living in fear as crime
runs rampant far left extremists are
getting whatever they want just real
quick uh their antifa was marching down
through the streets with rifles stopping
traffic and controlling the controlling
vehicles in in Portland and in Seattle
with Chaz chop like it's it's happened
all over you were saying Rich about
mental health I fully agree mental
health is such a problem right now and
the health the degraded health of the
country the minds of the people but like
and earlier we were talking about
utilitarianism and how like you have to
decide as a government well how many
chickens have to die in order for how
many eggs to be laid okay you cannot
quantify mental health utilitarianly it
cannot be done and the government
attempting to
figure out what's wrong with individuals
by making blanket medications is like
not working it has not worked gun
violence is not has not gone down I
could not more strongly disagree that
the government should be in a position
to decide you know how many chickens
especially when the chickens are an
analogy for human beings the government
is in no position to decide what humans
should and should not live I mean this
goes back to the argument that Tim was
having with Sargon the other day about
about the death penalty and whether or
not it's it's legitimate or not and that
your opinion on that aside the
government is a result of the consent of
the people the government does not have
a the right to to make decisions about
the people the people make decisions for
the government and this is a fundamental
fundamental principle of a free Society
the government's legit intimacy comes
from the consent of the governed and it
does not cut the government does not
exist to inform the people how they
should think what they should believe or
how they should organize their lives
period the problem and maybe you're
right that it could that that's ideal
but is that people will have faith in a
government to govern people they don't
know and that they'll never meet and
they'll send their tax money to that
organization and that government has to
make decisions about where is the food
going to go this this month who's going
to get it who's not going to get it so
that's what I mean who's going to live
who's going to die they shouldn't be
made that's that's what a market is for
that's why we have that that's why the
government shouldn't be involved in
markets but then you get a a individual
business leader decided like Vanderbilt
no shut off the trains to New York City
no look at all the I mean right now
you're talking about you're you're
talking about you know who's going to
get food and stuff grocery stores are
all over the country people can decide
where to go on their own and we don't
need the government to tell us how to
live our life back before 1860
Vanderbilt he owned all the trains in
the country basically he ran the country
oh arguably is the man who built America
Vanderbilt and he decided one day he
didn't like the way they were treating
him so he cut off access to New York
City he's like no you're not getting
trains in New York City anymore until
you until you meet my demands and we
realize how dangerous is to let the
private sector run I completely disagree
completely totally disagree with your
perspective and it is only the and if
you empower the government to do those
things then you are empowering the
government to decide who lives and who
dies who eats and who does not eat and
the gut and any government in history
that has had that power has abused it
and it turns into piles and piles and
piles of dead human beings let me just
because you got you you haven't gone so
far as to really argue the point of a
modern Democrat but what you guys are
arguing is a modern Democrat would say
but the government is the people and you
hear AOC actually say this all the time
absolutely not and I agree with you
right and to I would say in response to
what you're talking about because I get
it the Gilded era I get it I would
rather deal with the guild
than a government
that's just the way that that's where
I'm at the government has unlimited
power to coerce you to hurt you to you
know there's never going to be a guy
who's so rich he's going to be more
powerful than the Central Intelligence
Agency or the Federal Bureau of
Investigation I mean well not in this
Society you know maybe not in a true
market or something but they're not a
true market you know if we if we stuck
no you know to our uh original you know
if we stuck to our original design
original they there's I don't know why
they named it this now but
um as I did work on this for a book they
called it virtue capitalism like
somewhere along the lines
um we need to re-emphasize some virtues
that are about capitalism and to me and
it's like have you read Max vapor the
Protestant ethic and the spirit of
capitalism that's not capitalism so the
the pursuit of greed for greed's sake
has been around since Antiquity yeah and
since communism too that's exactly right
it's everywhere it has nothing to do all
right so when a you hear AOC make those
points it's like well that's not what
capitalism is at its core and again uh
I'd I'd rather deal with a greedy fat
cat you know who's got competition with
monopoly laws you know anti-monopoly
laws things like that then a government
because somewhere along the line
Democrats started to believe what he was
arguing against the government's enforce
the ant the monopoly laws that's true
that's true but we're not talking about
to the point of that that's different
you have a justice system for that
that's of within reason we're not
talking about uh the ability to to chop
up I don't Parts I don't believe the
United States could be communist that's
why one of the reasons I think we're
winning I I think we can see communist
influence but the backlash that we're
seeing in response to a lot of this
stuff is is the natural reaction I don't
know about never but not now I think
never you think Never Never Say Never I
mean well like like let's be realistic
nothing's absolute right for all we know
like a plague hits wipes up most of the
population and then a new civilization
number just calling it something that
says yeah there's a lot of circumstances
I'm saying based on the current
iteration of our government and our
culture today the systems that we have
in place uh in all likelihood will will
not right what about fascists see that's
I never I never liked when the right
always said no no Obama's a socialist
he's a
fascists with the Federal Reserve if you
look at if you look at the Soviet Union
if you look at communist China we may
get Civil War but I do not think we
would get you know a lot of people ask
us we'll say like is it a civil wars or
a Communist Revolution and will
interchange but let me let me break this
down and clarify when I'm when I'm
talking to my friend uh I was I was uh
visiting Ukraine covering some stories
there and the the apartment where we
stayed used to be Soviet communist
blockhousing and she explained how the
the apartment she was in back in the day
the two neighbors hated each other and
so one neighbor called the secret police
and said they were speaking bad about
the party the next day the apartment was
cleared out everything was gone that's
it neighbor taken care of that might
happen in U.S cities
but the the I do not believe that uh if
the United States ever went that kind
that to that degree of authoritarian it
would be ubiquitous outside of cities
for example when they did all the
coveted lockdowns
in most red areas nobody did anything
and even when they had those rules a lot
of them did they don't have the means to
enforce it and when people are living
successfully out in the middle of
nowhere they're just going to do
whatever they want for the most part and
they do they are parts of West Virginia
where it's like sure you're supposed to
get a permit for that and then people
build whatever they want and everyone
just rolls their eyes because like what
are you gonna do you're you're 70 miles
from the nearest uh town this is one of
the things that affected West Virginia
when it came to uh this gun bill that
the Democrats wanted to do where it was
like you had to go all gun transfers
must be through ffls
because uh some guy pointed out that
he's in rural West Virginia with like
really crappy internet and the nearest
FFL is like two or three hours away if
he needs to give a shotgun to his cousin
who lives down the road so his cousin
can deal with like some raccoon problem
or something because of his chickens
he's gonna drive three hours with his
cousin to go fill out paperwork that's
insane and and so that's that stuff does
not work and so there's a lot of things
that are federally restricted that are
not like look for I'm not talking about
drug deals I'm talking about there are
laws putting the gun sales and there are
people who live in the middle of nowhere
who they're not going to tell you but
they don't follow any of those laws and
no one knows and no one cares and it
will not be enforced no no ATF guy is
going to drive out to a trailer 300
miles from the nearest town for a guy
who lives on 200 300 acres of worthless
property where he just entertains
himself and Minds his own business and
then bought a gun from his neighbor for
a couple hundred bucks with a private
sale they're not going to drive out
there for that I mean they might but for
the most part it's just off the grid
they can't even find it if they wanted
to yeah when it comes to the overt
communist stuff
there's not enough federal law
enforcement to deal with the size of
this country if they tried to be a
secret police that were going and
erasing people for speaking bad about
the party in cities no question in
cities we already watched people in
Staten Island get arrested because they
were saying hey don't bring these
non-citizens into our neighborhood yeah
if you live in Staten Island you're a
subject okay you're not a citizen you're
a subject for those of us that don't
live in these big cities well for the
time being we still have our freedoms
and we are not subjects
subject only to the U.S dollar well kind
of not even I mean some flight people
are trading with all sorts of things
especially in the middle of nowhere but
uh but my point is this I'm not saying
they won't try but they will not be they
the amount of force you would need to
maintain full scale authoritarian
communist control over a country like
this yeah
the the issue here is people here are
just obstinate it's it's hard but I
agree it it would be hard but both China
and the Soviet Union were both massive
massive thinking long and hard so it's
not that it's it's not that not that I
don't think that you're you're right
about the the fact that it would be
tough but I think that what what happens
is you get violent uh coming the
government coming down violently with
the boot and then it scares people into
compliance but right so the issue is
China has a history of dynasties Russia
has monarchs the United States has
fractured colonies struggling to agree
with each other who are in Revolt first
the people who came to the United States
from Europe were people who are willing
to die to get away from whatever was
going on in their home country quite
literally like you're in the UK and
you're like this sucks can't practice my
no freedom of religion I don't want to
be here hey if you get on this boat and
ride for three months with a 20 chance
of dying you might make it to a Barren
Shore and they're like sign me up and
I'm like wow as an alternative to
conflict within your Country Escape was
an option they took it
the United States then is bread of
people who want to be left alone and
it's it's like out still isn't our
identity you're right and listening to
you and I'm thinking but can't look at
how people have changed are we still the
you know but but look at it this way
take a a small cellular culture of angry
people who say don't tread on me and
then put a few drops in a big petri dish
and then watch over a month as that
whole thing spreads and you can see it
is of the same culture there's mutations
there's changes you've some other cells
have creeped into the petri dish but
it's still overwhelmingly is this one
type and it just so happens this cell is
resistant to a certain virus
that is in our blood As Americans which
is why I would not be surprised if the
immigration problem is intentional to
destroy yeah to bring in as many people
as possible who are not of the pioneer
don't tread on me ethos but they're
trying to get as many people in this
country who are of the ethos of gimme
gimme gimme I will take what I want then
it's very easy to control people when
you give them what they want to quote
Fast and the Furious 4. when the villain
says he says give the people something
that they fear losing and you can
control them well there you go well
there's only one reason why there's only
one reason why majorcus would threaten
Cubans who are coming 90 miles you know
on so uh on on a raft or about the hill
threaten opens fire on them right but
he'll let anybody pour through the
southern border from certain countries
that he particularly wants it is
Venezuelans though too yeah
it's hard though it's hard to separate
Venezuelans you know from uh the rest of
the past it is Cuban's on a boat you
know and yeah a lot of people from
Honduras and the sentiment among most of
these migrants is uh they want they want
a better life and I can I get that the
American ethos was also very similar but
the thing about the people who came here
is and there's an overlap which is why I
say I respect people who are coming here
because they're willing to risk death
for the most part they're getting
funding there's stories about ngos
paying their bills this is very very
different big business you weren't you
weren't landing on a Barren Shore the
colonists were like we're going to land
on a Shore it's going to be hard work
and when winter comes you're probably
gonna die then too life is rough the
people who are coming here are like once
you get here you are going to live in
luxury compared to where you came from
so there's an inversion as to what the
economic what the drive is my point
ultimately is this nation is born and
bred of people who are really angry and
want to be left alone to the point where
they like are willing to die to be left
alone which means
look man
you know that the feds rated that fat
old dude's house because he was smack
talking on the internet and they killed
him
that's like that doesn't stop if this if
if the country does Go full Kami Tanki
whatever cities will be bad and they
will try to enforce thing outside of for
enforce things outside of cities but
what I think is more likely to happen
is that cities will be barred from
leaving people will yeah that's right
they'll have checkpoints around the
cities there's a bunch of sci-fi uh
movies and novels that are like this
where the people who live in the cities
very technologically advanced very
comfortable but you're not on the leaf
and the people from outside the cities
need special permits to come into the
cities there's like a Trilogy I'm
thinking of right now because I've I've
thought the same thing that you're just
not going to be able to go and they'll
try to make it as super cushy and
comfortable for you even though it is
Draconian ah what is the name of these
but they're trilogies they wouldn't let
the Surfs leave the land but there will
be my wife's gonna kill me for not
really there will be Backwater rural
folk who are surviving on their own
that's fine and you go to a city and
they're going to stop you and be like do
you have your permit yeah do you have
your do you have your social life these
stories you know what's over that wall
yeah
they're doing this in Saudi Arabia the
line that City where they're seeing they
want to build it that's yeah right
Divergent Divergent
it's yeah there's diverge and then
there's like there's two others research
and yeah so in the first one only
applies though Tim because they you
learn later it really is an experiment
to try to weed out bad genes yeah
because many many years ago like in our
time
um they started to you know I don't like
the color of my eyes I think I want blue
eyes so I'm gonna pluck out my my brown
or whatever I have uh greenish Brown
um and I'm gonna have blue eyes I'm
gonna change my DNA well we did it so
much we tainted our DNA so they made
this experiment to try to find what is
Divergence but inside the cities what
are they doing to those diverges hunting
them and killing them and you can't
leave because if you leave first of all
everything outside the wall is scorched
there's no world left it's Baron out
there don't even look you don't even
look yeah it's great and they don't want
people with bad genetics to get out
there because then that'll mix into the
for all you know right now there is an
entire Galactic Federation and human
colonies on other planets and the ships
that are flying by are the uh you know
we View North Korea yeah wow they're
locked in they're clueless they believe
all this game started in this I'll go on
okay so these alien ships were seeing
that they're lying to us about servers
it's humans from the other space
colonies who are like these poor people
living under this despotism who are
denied Intergalactic technology I'm
kidding by the way but you know you
never know you never know you like I
always talk about when uh when I was
younger we're teenagers and my friends
are all smoking weed I didn't smoke but
we'd be like it's it's like a question
probably every every friend group has
asked what if we're North Korea what if
like we think we're right but really
we're the ones
and it's like well you're only saying
that because you don't have a passport
you didn't go to you didn't travel
around here you know but it's a good
question right because how do you know
speaking of cernovich the other day at
the abortion issue the guy they were
talking about going to hell for uh not
being sufficiently pro-life and uh
speaking of speaking of cernovich he was
just like how do you know you're not
dead yet how do you know you're not dead
right yeah what are you talking to or
you're I'm laughing because I thought it
was hilarious for all you know you could
be playing Rich Barris too that's a
pundit experience and you're and you're
like a three-year-old mirror baby you're
a 53 year old Mexican guy who's at the
arcade right now yeah I think one of the
things that gives me a lot of Hope like
almost like at the base of what I am is
I've got this hope because American
Freedom the way that we've designed this
is the best form of government on Earth
it's not clear yeah so far and other
people in other countries know it and
they they agree like when I talk to kids
in China I used to do a chat roulette
back when it was cool and I just
roulette onto some Chinese dude or some
girl and we'd talk about it and they'd
be like we're in China it's crazy in
China you can barely get access to this
and I was like they all want it they all
like don't speak English and like I
don't know all this hyperbock but so
many people want this as their
government type dude
yeah that's contagious it's contagious
and I would say there there is a trick
though the Chinese
started to pull on their population and
that is and I I only know this from
having Chinese friends that I met you
know back in college
they were trying to convince them that
they were no longer the party of
Tiananmen Square right yeah we're
pragmatists it evolved yeah we've we've
evolved and we're pragmatic and we
really want to shift but still what did
they do to trick them and that's
interesting what you're saying I'm
agreeing they tricked them by saying
we're going to make our government more
liberal more we're going to open up the
markets we want you to have what a lot
of people in the west have and of course
that was all total nonsense they wanted
to exploit the west and if it made their
own population more comfortable than
then you know double win twofer
um but they had convinced them that they
were a more moderate party and this is
before
um this was you know yeah is that when
they change it to president they changed
chairman to president now they call
their leader the president and now that
was before even before that yeah anyways
I don't think that they the word that
they would use in English matters to the
Chinese they don't yeah
yeah so chairman is the proper word but
I guess because
of Communists were taking over they were
like just call my president yeah because
then it sounds Democratic it's better
yeah yeah they want you they want you to
they they want you to favor look if
communism favorably right the way you
think that he's a president like he's
elected which he technically is but but
I will say communism would be really
really awesome it would be the greatest
thing ever as long as I'm in charge
no no I'm not saying it'll be good for
anybody else yeah obviously if I'm in
charge I'm gonna be living it up yeah I
mean I'm gonna get morbidly obese I'm
gonna wear one of those silly little
military uniforms and everyone has to
worship me like a god that's basically
the mentality of Communists they're all
like I can't wait till communism wins so
that I can be in charge
so this is a little exciting we'll be in
charge of the rock breaking line in the
gulag ah so I don't know if anyone hears
heard of it but there was there was uh
khrushchev's midnight speech is where he
admitted all of Stalin's uh atrocities
right and that was really the first the
beginning of the falling apart of of the
Soviet Union as Khrushchev said look
Stalin did all these terrible things
millions of people died Etc
and in the speech Khrushchev is talking
about how Mark said that you needed to
avoid a cult of personality right but
yet if you look at all of the Socialist
uh all the socialist countries in almost
all of the social socialist countries in
history there's always a country uh Cult
of Personality there was there's there
was uh Mao in China there was Pol Pot in
in Cambodia every single time there was
there was Castro there's Chavez there's
and there's others that are smaller that
I can't think of off the top of my head
but they always have a cult of
personality the people always Focus
their attention on one leader and
somehow that person embodies what the
perfect perfected socialist man of their
time is and it is it is always as if it
is a you know uh it's a strong man well
yeah but it's it's more it's more than
just it is a strongman but it's it's
like a it's like because it's it's
treated as a religion the society in and
of itself it treats the the ideology as
a religion and so they focus on one
person as the pure socialism
yeah it's like a book like a little red
book with uh with yeah for instance yeah
it's it's like a feature of it I wrote
about this in my in my district it's
what concerns me right so real quick
though just because yeah we mentioned
those
um how many uh military dictators or
right-wing dictators can you name
was he left what country but he really
was I spent time in Chile that's why I
know that was there an actual dictator
[Music]
Batista was was right-wing in Cuba
before
um Fidel Castro yeah yeah but I got I
gotta ask this though what are we really
calling right wing are we having the
normal right I said when you say it yeah
when you say Franco is right wing it's
like that's a that's from a very
left-wing perspective to call him that's
right right you know that's why I said
military dictatorship right right that
makes it perfect yeah
um one thing I was going to say is I'm
concerned about the cult of personality
in American politics big time like I I
don't think that Trump has any communist
Ambitions but the the cult of
personality that was so eminent and
communist regimes I see it in the United
States from time to time the fervents
the willingness to go against what you
believe because Alexandria
ocasio-cortez obsession with politicians
in general she's so famous but that's
Humanity but that's the Brilliance of
our founding fathers they they they and
even Washington they wanted to do it to
him yeah and uh you know that's within
us that's human nature and it's yeah
it's access to resources it's in it's
your your desire to live to be able to
progeny like to have progeny it's the
desire to you know probably one's
oneself this is part of why I'm so
concerned about
um uh Obama Michelle Obama because
Michelle Obama would Inspire that kind
of fervent dedication she's this she's
she's someone we need to look up to et
cetera now I'm not saying that she would
be a tyrant that would you know be like
all right we got to start killing people
as like someone like Mao or whatever but
that kind of adoration we saw people
adore Barack Obama and it would be the
exact same thing with Michelle Obama
probably even more so people would adore
her
Obama is cool
whether you agree with him or not the
truth is you know it's just gonna be
because I want to give a uh an example
Hillary Clinton had a more than 60
approval rating when she was the
Secretary of State favorability people
love him then she ran for president
everyone realized this moment you know
well what do you mean she had hot sauce
in her purse yeah I mean oh God you know
it was funny when she announced that the
Michelle would have to hide the show she
was on they were like sounds like you're
pandering to black people and she goes
is it working is it working yeah
that's so gross you think Michelle would
you think she'd have to hide so she
wouldn't go down in favor she would
crash Americans would vomit when they
start to get to know her uh they tried
to do this I got kids
um Nickelodeon
every Saturday morning watching early
morning cartoons with my kids they had
this woman Kamala Harris
aspire to be Kamala Harrison and I'm
sitting there with my little daughter
watching you know like uh you know what
what is that miraculous or something and
I'm thinking of myself and not even
thinking to myself it's this woman
is not who you want to be because does
anybody really want is any father want
their daughter their little daughter to
grow up and emulate Kamala Harris I hope
not is that how you want your daughter
to behave no you know so she was
supposed to be popular this is why
Democrats are in a pickle right now
right she was supposed to be popular
silver let's hold them she would be
popular it's because they listened to
woke Twitter yes and they were like so
we go for this you know first female VP
woman of color we're gonna be great and
everyone's like she is one of the most
despicable human beings
yeah she was like Buffy the Vampire
Slayer versus Dracula when she took a
stake to the heart of the demon and said
Kamala Harris imprisoned innocent people
arrested them for pot and it's just like
and she used them as slave labor and
it's like what I thought she was gone
after that initial debate and then there
she reared her her head better better
Phoenix better analogy is that Kamala
Harris was standing at the podium and
and uh Tulsi gabbard took a bucket of
water and splashed it on top of her and
then Kamala went okay but then that DNC
started banging the drums
we don't have anyone else what do we do
it's actually here let's let's roll with
it they took the sludge after Tulsi
gabbard splashed the water brought it to
the lab and hooked electrodes up to it
and then cranked the lever I think we
got her and they were like
run the Democratic ticket and be cool
I'm telling you know
Gavin Newsom and he was getting creamed
and that's because people don't really
know who he is yet yeah but I feel like
Ron DeSantis for instance is about to
raise his profile big time okay I'll say
it I'll say like this you cannot be a
Democrat and be cool and you cannot be a
traditional Republican and be cool I'm
sorry yeah like it so the only thing
that can come close to being cool
is probably some form of
anti-establishment
Trump and like like moderate Trump
supporter to a certain degree yeah maybe
like the closest you'll get to it would
be an Ian Crossland yeah something like
that so I'm like because you can't lie
if you lie you're not cool in the Modern
Age yeah like if if a 19 year old finds
out you're lying to them you're you're
off the island you're done but to be
fair I mean like Ian is cooler than 99
of the uh uh of Congress yeah and that's
Democrats and Republicans combined
Democrats have no cool Factor they have
no bench yeah this is a this is a real
problem for them they have they have no
bench uh P Buddha judge uh you know had
some talent in 2020 he did better than
people thought he was going to do I
think there's obviously some appeal he
had at least to the left there but then
he ran the transportation department and
proved to be totally incompetent and he
went then he got hired and didn't go to
work for him right that's what I'm
saying
adapting a base this is why you can't be
a Democrat and be and be cool the
Democrats imagine we are all in high
school the Democrats are the preppy kids
yes exactly the Republicans are like
somewhat
like preppy but they have a few people
who like the bad boy wearing the leather
jacket and the blue jeans with the SWA
the Suave blonde hair going forward
sitting in the back being like she's a
fat pig over there and they laugh now
if you want to win class president you
got to basically get everybody but the
stodgy nerdy kids who are teachers pet
are not cool and so amongst themselves
they think they're cool yeah they're
like dude did you see that gem he got
straight A's and it's like wow and then
everyone else is like who cares man he
can run so fast so you need you need a
combination of someone who's talented
reasonable authentic and doesn't come
off as stodgy and the Democrats don't
have any of that because they started to
with um and I'm sorry to interrupt but
RFK and then they're just like no he's
too cool get him out of here sorry I
mean he's still he he's the coolest
Democrat but he's not that cool yes if
you want that's why if you watch Gavin
in the spin room after the debates which
uh I only did you know after the fact
you could tell that he's trying to be
almost like a left-wing version of
Donald Trump he's trying he's straight
yeah a hate he wants the right to hate
him so the left is loyal to him and this
is something that I think is a danger
with RFK and people may underestimate
the hive my that Democrats are
if RFK runs against the DNC like this
and he gets pegged for instance as
someone who is anti
Democratic like he becomes like their
enemy
then he won't peel that many off he has
to do it the right way I think Gavin
understands that and he wants the right
to hate him because if the right thinks
it'll Garner him respect and people will
then because they hate him that means
I'm good yeah
exactly let's pause real quick go and
look at it let's define cool
oh yeah he's not cool I'm I'm literally
saying let's let's define exactly what
it is we're talking about chill uh so
cool actually means too many things uh
cool means like as an adjective
describing a person could actually mean
like cold it could actually refer to
something calm and collected yeah like
right like a razor so but it does it
it's a a combination of how we use cool
to describe someone it's charismatic
confident attractive fashionable they're
look they're look you you look up to
them and healthy I think uh I think
charisma and and a desire a desire to
emulate coolness represents desire to
emulate yeah right when someone is wrong
you know when someone is cool you are
saying they they behave act and have the
things that we look up to and desire for
ourselves yeah uh not necessarily have
things but it's a combination of like
high high social status I guess uh
displaying uh uh like just displaying
proper High higher social status of some
sort yeah you want them around so you
look at it this way AOC at a party
okay you know whatever she's not the
least cool person but she's like pretty
close she's nerdy right she like
Democrats are all stodgy nerdy the
preppy types Republicans oh 10 times so
but there's a handful of Republicans
where you'd be like that are cool cool
ish it's because the interesting thing
is with the culture War cool is actually
fractured right now so uh there's a
handful of Republicans who are cool-ish
ladies cool it's cool JD Vance yeah I
don't know in person he's cool yeah
maybe but like you're saying cool isn't
like he's a good guy no I mean like uh
he's like like a you know an average
dude yeah that's not cool yeah average
is not cool no I don't mean like he's
approachable
qualities
you should have him on the show a failed
musician Phil is cool okay
well no but look
don't worry man five five Gold Records
platinum record opening for Metallica
but he doesn't talk about it that's
what's cool well no but like he's chill
Phil is successful and uh uh uh but like
you've done things that everyone wishes
they've done yeah you do talk about it
but you know and I don't I don't Lord it
over people and it doesn't mean that I'm
bad does it mean that the first time in
the world well no like a very degree is
cool but on average you would say a rock
star is cool Democrats don't have rock
stars Republicans don't have rock stars
no Republicans have slightly more than
anybody else that's about it for some
reason there are things that are that
are cool and things that are not and
it's really weird yeah it's hard to
define the thing too about the demo but
like I think sorry just just real quick
to clarify my point not to single out
fill Rockstar is considered to be
objectively cool successful musician and
Entertainer is considered to be an
objective I would say drugs are
objectively cool but they're not anymore
with Pharmaceuticals
smoking is objectively cool looking but
it's not cool to do but you you look at
P you look at someone smoking and
there's always is that attitude thing
that goes along but now it's holding a
cigarette like this and yeah like
lighting it and not even smoking it and
looking around like you don't care yeah
there's there's something about that
yeah
it's it's like this is yeah
but like uh uh having having almost no
fear no care you are aggressive you're
assertive you are confident you are you
lack worry people want that in their
lives that's the point I was trying to
make the Punisher makes the the current
Democrat I guess you could say like the
ideal person is very uncool they're
always the person complaining about
something that's good that's saying oh
like that's annoying that's oh oh that
you're like this oh well that's
problematic because of this they're like
oh then that's exactly the opposite of
what someone that's cool that doesn't
care that it is like you know aloof like
you said it's like the Democrats okay
you're at a house party and then Trump
shows up with a keg yeah and it's a high
school he is obviously cool yeah and and
and he's like and he's he's not the
football player yeah he's just a big
dude he's overweight he's kind of funny
and snooty but he brings the keg and
then the Democrats are the ones being
like um you're not old enough to drink
dude we're gonna get in trouble exactly
why are you bringing this here there is
like nothing you don't have to be here
for partying man there's nothing less
cool than people that are trying to haul
monitor you yes I know the people I
don't understand why the left isn't
rejected by more people that want to go
just just out of hand because if you're
gonna sit there and be like oh that guy
swore
he's got a bad he's got a bad opinion he
said this correctly literally it's like
the hall monitor you're awesome
the guy that goes and runs to the
teacher is never the guy
they know they have a cool problem and
I'll give two personal examples one I'm
not saying anyone in this room are the
coolest people in the world or that
we're more deserving no I'm just saying
the Democrats definitely have a cool
problem yeah but I will say
and this is personal when we did the
skate thing in DC I brought the story
before but I'll get more detail uh I've
put out some skate videos uh recently we
filmed a few Clips we went skating and
we had uh Sean hover shout out cool dude
uh Pro Skater and uh we're skating in
the barn and uh I'm an old man I don't
skate as crazy as I used to I did a
handful of Tricks they're a little
sketchy he filmed them and uh the
barracks posted them this is the like
the big Escape brand in the world they
reap they post Clips periodically they
posted my clip they've posted other
clips of mine before and it was because
the tricks that I did a little sketchy
but they were particularly Advanced
tricks so I was really excited I did
with something called the fakie ghetto
bird and it was kind of sketchy oh
that's a hard trick and um comments are
pissed they're pissed when I was in DC
uh I announced like Hey we're gonna go
skate in DC and then these leftists the
super woke people got really really mad
and this Pro Skater sent me uh uh a link
to a forum a skateboard Forum where
people were talking uh talking smack
about me having been at DC Freedom Plaza
skating and so people were like he's not
a real skateboarder anyway and one guy
said Tim Poole couldn't even do a pop
shove it he's a poser blah blah and then
they all started trying to entertain
this live that I didn't actually skate
wide
cool Factor yep these people who are
complaining sucked they they don't they
don't have the talent or the Merit and
no one wants to film what they do
because they're not Landing anything
good yeah I didn't go there and say
anything to anybody I hung out my mind
in my own business but I was doing 540
big flips I was doing like you know uh
cancel flips hard flips hardfield late
flips minding my own business but
probably doing some of the harder tricks
at the spot I've been skating for for 24
25 years
so they they go on the internet and lie
because they need to maintain Tim pool
doesn't actually do this thing you know
he's no no Phil is a failed musician
Hassan says that why because Hassan
doesn't have anything there's no there's
nothing he's a guy he's a guy who
streams hey more power to him he's the
biggest left-wing streamer I respect
that there's there's literally he's
ripped yeah
but the reason he says uh that Phil has
failed and it's it's just like the worst
possible timing a week after opening
from Metallica and a few days before
getting a fifth gold record you don't
say these things but it's because they
have to make sure that there is no
charismatic cultural influence coming
from the anti-establishment faction at
all it's the preppy kids being like
don't like trying to keep the cool kids
out of school and and it's uh you know
what I got a really good example watch
The Decemberists video for um um what is
it 16 Military Wives I don't know it's
it's not necessarily the most perfect
example but the preppy uh the lead
singer of The Decemberists it's a good
song uh plant a slingshot in the locker
if the kid he doesn't like and then goes
to the principal and says look look he's
got a slingshot to get him in trouble
like they're trying to keep the
influences that threaten them away so if
they came out and and I I saw this as
really funny when um Hassan was
doing a review of the song we put out
will of the people the first song we put
out a couple three years ago uh he was
he was basically like sort of talking
smack and the comments for people being
like no this is Tim Poole oh man I like
this song oh No it's like oh oh come on
they they have to make sure they tell
everybody we're lame we suck we're not
good at anything yeah the the view of
anybody who votes Republican needs to be
a certain a suit wearing stodgy guy who
is uncool he's exposed to be the great
unifier too that really stinks and you
really I think really hit on something
that Republicans need to pay attention
to they need to be painted as the hall
monitors the speed Keepers yeah it's
like look I'm trying to I want to do 75.
okay get in the right lane that's right
Republicans and Republicans are
substantially okay so here's what here's
what I'll say I want to do 80. 95 of the
Republicans are substantially less cool
than Democrats yeah but there's only if
only because there's a handful of
Democrats that could moderately claim
they're they're somewhat cool however
there are a few Republicans who are
substantially cooler than all of the
Democrats speaking to your point what
Gavin Newsom is doing by talking about
he he actually called California the
freedom State and he's spinning it he's
spinning it trying to make it seem as if
the as if California is a cool is the
cool place where you can do what you
want you can live how you want et cetera
et cetera everyone knows that California
has the highest taxes in the in the
country or some of the highest taxes in
the country everyone knows that
California has
significant problems when it comes to
Crime when it comes to homelessness
human feces that's among them among the
problems but but if you listen to the
way that Gavin Newsom is trying to
reframe people's understanding of
California he is trying to point he is
trying to make people believe that he is
the cool candidate and that and that's
also what Joe Biden he's not he's
American Psycho I completely agreement
he likes Bateman they post the memes
that's true but I agree but that but you
it's it's speaking to the point that
you're making he is he sees the value of
being cool and he is trying to make sure
that he gets that for he gets that that
Ma he gets that into people's head
remember when Rhonda Sanders tried to be
cool
with the Bateman Meme and stuff it's
like bro listen you need you need to
understand what makes you cool and Ron
having that video put out I guess there
our campaign put it out and then
launched it through a third party or
whatever is what they do
Ron should not be bronze path to being
cool is unique to Ronda Santos and
making memes of glowing eyes is not the
way you do it no he should have done a
clip of him hitting a big bag of uh just
a back punching bag what makes Ron cool
is is like
just being relaxed and authentic and
being himself and owning it so uh the
the human behavior
someone someone in high school right
you're in high school everyone's sitting
around someone farts they get really
embarrassed they fart everyone laughs at
them for farting and say oh you did it
you're gross and the person blushes and
they're like oh man I'm so embarrassing
and they're like that's so gross then
there's the class clown who goes
attention class and then stands up and
rips one and then starts laughing his
ass off owning it and that that's what
more like Trump yeah Trump's the guy who
farts in the room and then starts
dropped an M effort tonight Trump did
yeah when we were talking he drops
we got to go to super chats we're way
late we're way late all right if you
haven't already smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
become a member at timcast.com support
our work we're gonna read your super
chats we got Clint Torres he's he's
taken over uh first place he says how do
people hi Clint he's uh can he's he's
been getting the first Super Chat in
every night that's true so uh you guys
um man it's been no competition did you
get the neural net Clint laser fingers
normally all right Ben says Dianne
Feinstein senator from California dies
at age 90. Ding Dong The Witch Is Dead
the power of attorney wasn't a joke then
I guess didn't you said just voted
recently she voted last night how for
the aviation uh funding so somebody
voted for her is that what it looks and
and honestly maybe it was a little bit
too soon I did say I did see somebody
earlier uh say that the Senate is again
amending its rule to continue to allow
Senator Feinstein to vote and chop a
little too early porkchopolis as I heard
Feinstein plans to run for re-election
from Beyonce
in the same mold
Jason Dixon says Tim can you please
shout out the discord's Friday after
show exclusively in Discord hosts are
Olivia Claire Joey cannoli and cinoski
kanoski yeah members welcome that's
right if you're a member at timcast.com
and you sign up to join the Discord
server there will be an after show
hosted by Olivia Claire Julie cannoli
and uh canowski it's kanoski right I
don't know yeah I don't know members
welcome and uh we we very much do
encourage it the look honestly the score
members started building their own stuff
yeah it's it's like you invite a bunch
of people into a room and then you come
back a week later and they've built like
a castle and I'm like oh wow thank you
that's right very nice it's very cool
people are doing that but I'm really
excited for the coffee shop when it gets
open at some point we're waiting on
permits because we have to do uh
construction stuff inside to keep it up
to code to update it okay but second
floor is going to be really awesome
because then members can come hang out
and we're really excited imagine all the
really cool stuff you can hang out with
people if you're in the West Virginia
area and DC and play games and watch TV
and and it'll be fun it'll be very very
fun let's grab some more Super chats
Griffin Street Studios has timcast
Discord is classist desperately needs
more features and groups for base level
10 a month members on the right track
needs more for us pores well you are 100
correct uh we're trying to figure it out
yeah what would be a good example I know
you just super chatted but of what you
could get at 10 like what would be a
good example hit us up let us know well
I mean on on yeah we're like we're we
are desperately trying but also consider
the membership typically was like we do
the after show and then we launched the
Discord as a mean to as a way to bring
callers in and then create a communal
space but uh this is this is this is
this is the tough spot it's like the
amount of people that we've added to
timcast membership by creating the cost
of the Discord does not cover the cost
of the Discord so just to show you guys
so like
awesome a certain amount of people will
sign up members to watch the after show
and support the work we do we then say
we're going to launch new shows with the
money we make we're going to open coffee
shop we're gonna buy we're gonna buy ads
we're gonna fight the culture War one of
the things we decided to do was launch
the Discord we don't make more money for
doing in fact it costs us more money to
run the Discord than we actually make by
having it but this is the point you know
what I mean like if like if you came to
me and asked me like hey what would you
buy if you had a million dollars I'd be
like I'd win the call I used to win the
culture War speed rush your theaters
we'd uh build your build your cultural
buildings yeah so like money's for uh
I'll I says before I say it again what
my salary is at timcast is based off of
the Tim pool morning show that I produce
and host entirely on my own 95 granted
the timcast infrastructure does benefit
to a certain degree like internet and
all that stuff
um but then I pay my salary entirely
based off of actually less than what is
generated from the Temple Daily Show
which is my morning podcast everything
else that comes from timcast.com
timcastirl basically just pays for other
employees all the cultural projects
working on the Discord server people and
people are asking in the chat they say
discord's free what do you mean they're
they're confused our our if you are a
timcast member we have a members only
Discord where you can hang out that's
that's paid for by the company as
they're saying the members only Discord
is paid for we we we pay for yes I'm
like members pay to sign up to our
exclusive members only Discord which
gives you access to website stuff and
and they sync yeah it's like free to
have Discord yeah but in order to be
accessed or have access to our forms and
everything like that you have to pay I
think people also don't realize that we
have staff members who maintain and run
and build the things people are asking
for every day yeah like we have a
full-time like Brett's full time running
the Discord 100 yeah and then right so
the amount of users that we have does
not like okay so before Discord we have
X users we launch Discord we gain a
little bit people are like oh this is
really interesting I really shouldn't be
involved but the cost of running Discord
is more than the members we added yeah
yeah I get it that solves the question
so it's like we definitely want to
promote the Discord and make it to the
point where we can invest in expanding
anything but again I will stress this
the money we get from everything like
Tim cast IRL timcast.com memberships
we're investing in the Discord for you
guys to have a communal space we're
launching this club so that people will
have a physical space to go hang out
I guess I could argue like I don't have
to do any of that I could just put the
money in my pocket and say it's my
business it's private company I'll go
buy a bunch of cars and then buy a
private jet or something but I'm I'm
fairly happy with the money I get from
the morning show and I want to win the
culture War so that's why
I'll give you an example we put up
Billboards in Times Square why it's
promotion it's marketing obviously but
we added Michael Miles and lukerkowski
to them because promoting them in my
view helps win the culture War things
like that I'm thinking of civilization
it's like you can with money all you can
do is build the theaters and the Opera
Houses but the with the only way you can
create the great works is with the great
people you need the people money doesn't
buy the people no substitute
so one thing I've I've purchased for
myself
um with my money is we're building a
frog pond a frog a frog tell me more uh
we have a little frog pond and then
frogs will swim in it bullfrogs probably
they're everywhere all over the place
frogs and turtles and sometimes they
jump all the way out here and then
they're just standing in the grass and
I'm like let's build a frog hey a little
frog there's no cultural Victory I'm
sorry but I wanted one pawns are awesome
I got one I don't know how to stop it
it's called my pool and I can't keep
them out and I feel bad because they die
oh yeah yeah they well we have the you
know the salt one but they get stuck in
the skimmer can't get out let's uh I
gotta read this one uh Sam FS Claire
says Tim the British man who exposed
that Canada applauded a Nazi in
Parliament Warren Thornton was arrested
under Mal information Phil is correct we
are in the maoist revolution now please
read this and people please wake up we
are in it so what happened with this guy
yeah yeah I heard about this
um so remember how the Canadian
Parliament applauded yeah uh apparently
they really did start the dispute
whether or not uh you know it was as bad
as everyone said it was and I didn't
read the story but I did see something
on Twitter that appear the rest of the
guy there come I don't know if they
arrested him but I did see them go like
criticized they might have they very
well might have what's that wouldn't be
surprised what's it guys I don't know I
just saw it you know scrolling on the
timeline but
um
I mean
we don't know where the line is you know
Tim I understand what you're saying but
we don't know the line between that
snowball when it everything goes slow
and then it just becomes gradually then
suddenly yeah uh Mike oxhard says this
really makes me worried for RFK the
Kennedy curse will be on steroids if he
is the reason for about in losing
against none other than Trump yeah
Greedo says the next civil war here in
the United States will be more like the
city-state Wars of Italy where king of
bohemia challenged the pope for control
of the country and the city-states broke
up on different sides what year was that
this is like 1300s like bologna and
Medina had a famous battle over like the
bucket yes wow pretty cool stuff I'm
playing as a Venetian Patriarchs and
Crusader Kings 2 right now bojiven says
Tim where is the culture War podcast and
why was the FBI whistleblower episode
removed please be transparent with loyal
viewers if not ignore the Super Chat uh
it is it was in me so it was live we
took it down and upload it as a
standalone video so it it's still there
right yes yes it's on YouTube yeah it
just doesn't appear in the live tab
it'll appear in the videos tab because
we uploaded it as a VOD that's probably
what they're doing why there was no
episode today because our guest canceled
on us on Monday our backup guest
canceled on us uh Thursday morning
and then it's like okay well sometimes
this happens yeah but you know it is
what it is and uh
couldn't do anything about it we should
just Jam next time that's too early no
we had a backup we have a triple backup
plan but uh I said I said no it was like
it's basically like we had a really
really really great guest that was very
difficult to book and they canceled on
us again and uh upset about that and
then we have uh a backup roster of
people who are interested in coming on
and we said hey we have the spot opened
up and this is Monday can you come and
then they missed their flight
and we're like I'm just not coming and
we're like okay and then our our final
plan was let's do a cultural episode
with our existing friends and guests and
it's like
I don't think we can pull that off not
not we have to plan for it better but
the idea was just to get like people
you've already known who we hang out
with just to come and hang out again and
and Rogan does this that's why he'll
have his buddies on oh yeah those fight
Companions and stuff but that works
because that's his only show for us to
take IRL friends and guests into a
culture War episode defeats the purpose
of what the culture war is right so I
was like
if we could get literally anybody else
we could have like two IRL friends with
any other person and then have a
conversation that's unique that we don't
do in IRL but I don't know I don't know
who the guests were and I don't need to
know but I saw it I'm gonna drag him
from Destiny vosh and Emma vigland were
all in DC shooting a video I watched
them all talking at a table I would love
to have them over and do that here well
you know Phil was Phil's pointing out
that's because of us right yeah we
started we started doing podcasts and
with Congress and now all of a sudden
the left is trying to do it that's what
it seems like to me I I imagine people
in Congress took notice that you know
Tim Poole is up there at Capitol Hill
talking to Congress Congress people and
they started to say oh hey that's a
smart idea especially considering you
know it is going into the election
season right now you know well good for
them I'm glad they did it yeah I wish I
would have known I would have uh uh
would have asked Destiny if he could
have come now because we could have had
another oh yeah because that would work
for another culture sure best thing is
good yeah uh I I Destiny and vosh I
think would be a good conversation oh
you're wild Emma I thought was a bit
silly yeah it looked pretty cool I only
got 10 minutes of what they were doing
but it looked pretty nice that they're
out there actually it would have been
epic if we had uh Destiny vashmi and
Phil and did a culture war that would
have been
yeah maybe we should reach out to him
see if they want to do it yeah would you
want to do it I'll do it yeah that'd be
epic yeah
no vosh asked me to come on and watch
one time wanted me to come on to his
stream and I turned him on tonight
because I'm not going on vasha Street
things are communist because he's I'm
not going to help him monetize yeah
whatever man I I you know I get it I do
I'm not gonna create a good good
capitalist well yeah I mean the thing is
like you know he wants to have the rock
star on him I'm sorry but you don't just
get to have the Rocks
that's all there is to it but this is
why they have to call you failed that's
right they they have to act like they're
cooler than everybody but to be fair I
will give I will give us on this first
as I said I have tremendous respect for
the success he has it's not easy it's
stupid to me when people are like
Trump's a he's a failure I'm like
no he's not he's a millionaire Taylor
Swift is awful she her music sucks I'm
like dude literally it doesn't she's
rich or not and Hassan clearly is
successful and has looked at by many
people as being a cool dude that's
totally fine I respect that but to to
his credit
a component of of being that charismatic
figure is controlling the narrative
around who is not so for Hassan to have
a massive audience act like a tough guy
and say he's cool that's a component
Trump is a tough guy who pushes people
around it's part of cool Factor yeah
it's hard it's a hard thing to Define
you know I don't like Bully cool
the epitome of it success really is it
actually the the cool kids that were
bullies made me hate Humanity so I've
got a you gotta be careful because
sometimes but they're different than
somebody like a Donald Trump is like I
mean people have to understand these a
lot of people call him a bully but when
you're him and you're constantly under
attack and you're constantly needing to
defend yourself uh it can't be easy to
be done you're right but as soon as
someone's nice to Trump he's nice to
them you know as much as that's his
currency that really is his currency
yeah he's a great listener Jason Dixon
says Tim none of the after shows hosts
and shows are paid full volunteers we
did it for free we do it for culture
this is fact fact true and correct what
the members are building in the member
Discord is completely organic and from
them based on the goodness of their
hearts and what they want to do and what
they think we need to do uh my point
about uh the cost of running Discord is
basically just the infrastructure staff
the the you know Brett runs it then we
have it people behind the scenes for
maintaining there's code involved in the
website integration and things like that
so there is a greater cost to it that
being said guys I am I am paying
attention to what's going on in the
Discord server and uh I'll just leave it
at that like I certainly think there's
an opportunity for something Beyond just
what we have and a way to uh do
something more for the shows that are
already in existence on the Tim cast
members only like there's no reason why
they shouldn't just be
filmed and so we'll talk about it when
we get the um
the uh uh Club setup I think it would be
really cool to actually get equipment
invest in it and have a desk provide it
for the member Community after shows and
then actually have the videos of videos
available alongside the shows on Discord
and just just film it and have them for
everybody yeah so all right everybody if
you haven't already uh please smash that
like button would you kindly And
subscribe to this channel share the
share with your friends head over to
timcast.com become a member next week we
are in Miami uh this is going to be epic
Luke will be on all week for the show at
a special studio location where we will
be filming Friday's show will be an
exclusive Members Only Live event with
Matt Gates Patrick Bet David James
O'Keefe and a ton of people are going to
be there the guest list of like yeah I
think it's like 20 plus people that you
are you guys know and love and um one of
the reasons why I said let's just we're
gonna do it members only the obvious
guys we really do try to build
memberships it's what runs the company
so if there's an opportunity and we're
doing an event and it's like well
if we're selling tickets to it giving it
away for free online defeats the purpose
of selling tickets we want we want to
build up memberships but the big
question that came up was hey someone
could sit in the front row and scream
bad things and we're like well then
we're gonna have to figure that one out
audio wise and it's like well you really
can't and it's like that's a fair point
maybe we should just take it off YouTube
and then I'm like
well if we just do it members only we
can literally go nuts
like actually go nuts people can talk
about whatever they want to talk about
no I I just say we can I'm not saying
I'm gonna
I'm not I'm not sure I'm gonna get naked
on Friday but it means we don't have to
worry we don't have to worry so much
we're gonna have the clips up the full
podcast will be available on Apple and
Spotify and all of that for the show
itself but it means that uh we're gonna
have all the time in the world for the
venue which means there's going to be a
pre after show uh with the special
guests we'll probably have people jump
up on stage periodically and just go
nuts and just have a really good time so
I'm looking forward to seeing everybody
there and become a member at timcast go
to timcast.com click join us that what
we're gonna we're gonna have two YouTube
videos put up next week explaining how
to sign up one on Monday and then one on
uh Friday just before the show for those
that want to watch it you can follow the
show at Tim cast IRL you can follow me
personally at timcast Rich do you want
to shout anything out yeah people can
just go ahead and follow me if they want
to check out the polls we're going to do
we're gonna find out who RFK hurts for
sure real soon uh they could do that at
people's pundit dotlocals.com That's
essential help Tim that's where that's
the only place you gotta go you'll see
it all from there
I am Phil that remains on Twix and I'm
Phil that remains official on Instagram
the band is All That Remains you can
follow us on Spotify Apple music Amazon
music YouTube Pandora you know the
internet I'm Ian Crossing you've got
follow me on the internet I will see you
next week in Florida I'm super pump Rich
great energy man good to see you again
dude always a pleasure thanks for having
me all the best brother oh yeah search
yeah I'm excited to be in Miami it's
gonna be fun uh hit me up on Twix I feel
like I'm close to another another
thousand per people which is cool uh
also follow me on Instagram would be
cool to get more on there it's anyways
too in Miami yeah it's gonna be sweet I
can't wait for Miami it's weird like
overcast West Virginia weather anyways
all right everybody thanks for hanging
out and the next time we see you we'll
be in Miami